MOMENTS WE DO NEED OUR SHE'S
COMMON.
SO WE'RE GONNA.
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
SO I LIKE TO SAY GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE.
THE STAFF WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WE'RE GONNA STAB WILSHIRE
CORMIER OKAY.
ARE.
ORGANISED AVERAGE THE QUORUM.
SHOP CALL THIS MEETING TO ORDER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE BATES.
BRADFORD.
DORADO.
TERRAZZO HERE HILL.
HILL HERE JONES.
THE CASKEY HERE BECAUSE HE HERE.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM -- WE
HAVE SIXTY NINE BILLS.
ARE ON OUR CALENDAR TODAY FIVE
ARE.
DO PASS MOTIONS I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE.
TWO AUTHORS THAT WANT TO PRESENT
TO ON BILLS THAT ARE.
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES AS WELL.
ARE THE REMAINING BILLS.
OUR SUSPEND CANDIDATES ALSO AB
TWO THIRTEEN BY RAY S. IN AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY KALRA ARE
STILL ON FILE.
BUT B	C WILL BE RESCHEDULED
FOR NEXT HEARING.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR BY HOLDEN
PERTAINING TO THE WILDFIRES.
IS BEING SENT HEARD IN SENATE
ENERGY -- AT NOON SO AT THE END
OF THIS IF IT GETS OUT -- WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS THIS HEARING --
TO DEAL WITH THAT BILL -- IF AND
WHEN IT COMES TO US LATER THIS
AFTERNOON -- AS A REMINDER I'D
LIKE TO REITERATE THE MESSAGE.
TO OF AUDIENCE MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS -- THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE AND YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RE LITIGATE THE POLICY
MATTERS SO WE'RE GONNA HEAR
ABOUT THE FISCAL.
SO PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENT THE
POLICY DISCUSSIONS IN.
SERGEANTS IF YOU COULD CALL WE
HAVE ONE AUTHOR HERE THE NEXT
ONE UP IN THE QUEUE WITH THE
MISTER DALY IF HE COMES OR ANY
OTHER AUTHORS.
THAT ARE PRESENTING THE DO PASS --
IS -- WHEN -- IS HERE TO PRESENT
ON HER SUSPENSE CANDIDATE --
MAYBE TWELVE SO PLEASE COME TELL
US ABOUT A. B. -- TWELVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A CHAIR PORTANTINO
AND SENATORS -- AB TWELVE IS MY
LEGISLATIVE RESPONSE TO THE
MURDER OF TWELVE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS LAST YEAR.
AT THE BORDERLINE BAR AND GRILL
THROUGH AN ACTIVE GUN VIOLENCE
THIS BILL MAKES A NUMBER OF
CHANGES TO TV ARE OWES INCLUDING
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO SET THE
TIME PERIOD FOR G. R. G. B. R.
O.FROM ONE YEAR TO A MAX OF
FIVE YEARS.
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE THE COST SAVINGS THIS
MEASURE WILL AUTOMATICALLY
ACHIEVED BY REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF COURT HEARINGS FOR LONGER
TERM JV ARE OWES.
IF THE JUDGE DOES DECIDE TO
ISSUE THE MAXIMUM FIVE YEAR
DURATION THE COURTS ARE
AUTOMATICALLY SAVED FIVE
EXTENSION HEARINGS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE ORDER.
THESE ARE TANGIBLE COST SAVINGS
THE FISCAL IMPACT FOCUS ON THE
ANALYSIS OF A REST ON MULTIPLE
LAYERS OF HYPOTHETICALS IF ANY
ORDERS ARE ACTUALLY ISSUED FOR
LONGER THAN A YEAR.
IF ANY OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
VIOLATE THE ORDER IF THE
VIOLATION WAS AFTER THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE ORDER.
IF THEY CAN TEST THE VIOLATION
OF REQUESTED JURY TRIAL OR
COUNSEL IF THERE ARE NO IF
THERE'S NO OTHER CRIMINAL
CHARGED INVOLVED IN THE TRIAL.
YEAH ANALYSIS CONCLUDES THAT IF
THIS LONG LIST OF HYPOTHETICALS
WITHIN AND ON WITH AND WHAT I
KNOWN CERTAINTY ACCURSED ELEVEN
TIMES WITHIN A YEAR THE SUSPENSE
THRESHOLD IS MATT.
OVER THE THREE YEARS OF TV ARE --
IMPLEMENTATIONS THERE'S BEEN
ONLY NINETY FIVE YOUR LONG
ORDERS THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON
ALLEVIATING BURDENS INCLUDING
COSTS ON THE COURTS FAMILIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ALMOST
CURRENTLY EXTEND GP ARE OWES ON
A YEARLY BASIS.
WHILE THESE CHANGES WOULD NOT
PREVENT THE OFFENSIVE BORDER
LINED -- IT IS MY BELIEF THAT BY
STRENGTHENING AND REFINING OUR
EXISTING GUN LAWS HAT WE CAN
HOPE TO PREVENT ANOTHER
COMMUNITY FROM EXPERIENCING THE
HORROR OF A MASS SHOOTING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS THIS BILL IS MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE.
THANK YOU IF YOU HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ARE.
THERE SOMEONE OVER THERE YES SIR
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS -- THIS IS
IN SUPPORT AND GT YEARS ON
BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I THINK OTHER PEOPLE ARE MOVING
AROUND YOUR COMING UP. FOR YOU
OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN EITHER DO IT THERE OR
COME UP WHATEVER YOUR CHOICES.
WELL IN IN THE INTEREST OF
BREVITY WILL JUST COME RIGHT
HERE.
CONTENT RE WITH NATURAL FELIZ SO
STATION HERE IN OPPOSITION TODAY.
WE FEEL THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
INCREASED COSTS ON ON FOLKS FOR
FOR A THE APPEALS PROCESS
OBVIOUSLY THESE ORDERS CAN BE
EXTENDED OUT TO UP TO FIVE YEARS --
THIS IS GONNA INVITE INCREASED
LITIGATION REMEMBER THESE ORDERS
ARE NOT BASED ON A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION OR MENTAL EDUCATION
BUT BASED ON THIRD PARTY
ALLEGATIONS -- FURTHER THERE
COULD BE LITIGATION BASED ON THE
LACK GUIDANCE TO A COURT ON WHEN
TO ISSUE AN EXTENDER OR BEYOND
ONE YEAR -- WITHOUT WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
THIS GERMAN MEMBER SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUNNELS CALIFORNIAN
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE -- THE THE
THE COSTS.
OUR REAL THE ALL OF THE THE WHAT
IFS.
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN SO -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS MEETS THE
THRESHOLD FOR SUSPENSE AND
SHOULD BE PUT THERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR MORE MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROY GRIFFIS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE FILE.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER OR GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MR TURN MEMBERS JULIE ON A DARE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU FOR ONE THIS BACK.
ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS THANK YOU --
FOR SUBMITTING IT THIS AND FOR
OFFERING TESTIMONY OBVIOUSLY
SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO BUT OF WHEN THINGS
DEAL WITH THE COURTS.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO TAKE A
DISCERNING VIEW AND IT'S THE
OPINION OF STAFF AND I AGREE
THAT THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE COSTS I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S GONNA SAVE IN SOME
PLACES.
SO IT'S GOING TO GO TO SUSPEND
TODAY BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
WITHOUT OBJECTION NINE A. B
TWELVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
I SEE MR COOLEY WAS IN THE HOUSE.
HERE WAVING PRESENTATION ON A.
B. FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY
PRESENTING ON S. A. B. --
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE MR COOLEY YOU
WERE NOT HERE -- WHEN I TALKED
ABOUT THIS IS THE FISCAL
COMMITTEE AND OBVIOUSLY PLEASE
CONFINE YOUR?
COMMENTS TO THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THE BILL WE'RE
NOT HERE.
TO REDO THE WORK OF THE POLICY
COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT.
SENT TO US ON AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE THE I..
S. POLICY JUST TO PRESENT THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THINK THERE IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT STATE INTEREST.
IN MAKING SURE INSURANCE.
LAWMAKERS CENTURY TWENTY HAVE
SOME KNOWLEDGE OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER.
THE UNUSUAL PART OF CALIFORNIA
LAW UNIQUE IN OUR CODES.
ARE MUCH OF THE INSURANCE CODE --
IS ARISE FROM THE WORK OF A BODY
KNOWS ANY I SEE.
THEY MAKE MODEL LAWS THAT THEY
COME INTO US TO ADOPT.
IT'S REALLY UNIQUE WITH OUR
SYSTEM OF LAWS THE FEEL OF
INSURANCE IS SUBJECT TO
DELEGATION TO AN UNELECTED THIRD
PARTY UNITY.
TODAY I SEE.
THEY RUN ACCREDITATION PROGRAM
THEY HAVE EIGHTEEN STATUTES DO
TO ADOPT -- AND SO THIS BILL
JUST ADDRESSES.
IN A WORLD IN WHICH SO MUCH OF
OUR INSURANCE CODE IS BY
DELEGATION TO A THIRD PARTY.
THERE IS A PUBLIC INTEREST IN
ENSURING THAT OUR LAW MAKERS ARE
INFORMED THE SUBJECT.
THE EXPENSE OF THIS BILL
SUPPORTS MAKING MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE INSURANCE
LAWMAKERS I CAN ATTEST THAT THE
NATURE OF IN A IN COIL MEETINGS
FOR EXAMPLE ARE SO INFREQUENT.
AND THEIR SCHEDULING OFTEN
CONFLICTS WITH OUR WORK.
I'M NOT TOO CONCERNED ABOUT ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE INSURANCE
CODE INTEREST PLEASE EVER MAKING
THESE MEETINGS.
BUT CERTAINLY AN INTERESTING
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE LAWMAKERS
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
FIELD.
SO -- I JUST WANT TO PRESENT
THAT ISSUE IT IS UNIQUE IN OUR
INSURANCE CODE THIS DELEGATION
FACTOR -- IF THERE IS A
REASONABLE WAY TO SELECT WHICH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD GO TO AN
COIL I'M ALL FOR THAT.
I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THEY'LL
BE A RUSH ON IT I THINK THE
PRACTICAL.
ANSWERS WOULD BE LIMITED.
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
pSERVICES FROM ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OZ THEIR FILE.
A YES WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WE
KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE -- ANTICIPATES THE
COST TO ADMINISTER THIS BILL
COULD BE APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE INSURANCE FUND.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B..
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AND WILL.
DEAL WITH FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
AS WE GO THROUGH OUR REGULAR
ORDER.
I SAW THAT -- IS QUIRK SILVA IS
HERE YOU'VE WAIVED ON AB ONE
THIRTY THREE BUT WANT TO PRESENT.
AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT ON THE
VETERANS CEMETERY AND AGAIN.
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
FISCAL AS THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE PLEASE COME TELL US
ABOUT.
AB.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT I WILL KEEP IT
VERY SHORT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS THIS BILL --
AND THIS VISION IF YOU WILL SIX
TO HONOR THOSE WHO HAVE A A
HONORABLY SERVED OUR NATION AND
I STAND BEFORE YOU IN
APPRECIATION THAT THE GOVERNOR.
AND OUR LEADERSHIP CHOSE TO PUT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TO OUR
BUDGET FOR THIS IN ADDITION
THERE IS.
TWENTY FOUR THERE IS FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION IN A CAL THAT --
ACCOUNT FOR THIS PROJECT AND WE
KNOW THERE'S WORK TO DO ON IT
BUT WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
YEAH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHASING AND
SOLVE AS REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF IRVINE JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON
THE RECORD THE CITY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATES THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE IT'S
BEEN -- SEVERAL YEARS IN THE
MAKING.
THE CITY IS SUPPORT WITH
AMENDMENTS WE HOPE TO HAVE FOR
DIRECTION FROM THE CITY LATER
THIS MONTH AS TO POTENTIALLY A
THIRD SITE.
WHICH MAY -- CLOSE THE FUNDING
GAP WITH WITH PRIVATE FUNDING --
BUT WE WILL AWAIT THE CITY'S
ACTION LATER THIS MONTH AND
AGAIN WANT TO OFFER SUPPORT AND
WILLINGNESS AND DESIRE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
OTHERS BEHIND YOU.
MR MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS ARE FORMER
VETS AND FAMILIES -- MEMBERS
THAT HAVE -- THAT OUR VETERANS
AS WELL IN A LEADER SUPPORT WHEN
THE BILL IS SET TO BECOME TAKING
OFF HIS PANTS THANKS THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION -- FILE.
YES -- WERE NEUTRAL THIS BILL
BUT WE DO KNOW CONCERNS WITH THE
COST OF THE PROJECT AT THIS
LOCATION A AS NOTED BY THE
AUTHOR OF THE BUDGET DOES
INCLUDE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR PURPOSES OF THIS PROJECT AT
THIS SITE.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS ESTIMATES THE
BILL HAVE UNKNOWN COSTS ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
A FROM THE MASTER DEVELOPMENT
FUND TO UPDATE THE EXISTING
STUDY AND PRELIMINARY DESIGN
WORK.
THAT WAS COMPLETED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN A WE CAN KERR -- BUT
KNOW THAT UNKNOWN COSTS WILL
RESULT FROM THE BILL -- ALTHOUGH
THESE ARE LIKELY TO BE
ACTIVITIES THAT WILL BE
PERFORMED DURING THE DESIGN.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
I'M ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL CLEANUP
ISTER CHAIR IS THERE HAVE THE
IDENTIFIED THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY
WHO CREATED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARD.
BECAUSE IF WE ACQUIRE AT THE
STILL HAVE.
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY FOR THAT.
WHAT WAS A FORMER MARINE BASE SO
WE KNOW THE FORMER -- EL TORO
MARINE BASE THAT WAS -- DEEDED
TO THE CITY SO IT WOULD BE THE
CITY OF IRVINE THAT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE WORKING ON IS LOOKING.
AT THE CLEAN UP -- ESTIMATE CAL
THAT CAME OUT TO DO A ANALYSIS A
FEW YEARS BACK AND GAVE A COST --
AT THAT TIME WE DID NOT SPECIFY.
HOW WOULDYOU MAKE A COSTS FOR
CLEAN UP FOR YOU IF YOU WERE
USING IT FOR RETAIL OR HOUSING?
THERE COULD BE ONE ESTIMATE AS
FAR AS CLEANING UP BUTIF YOU'RE
USING IT FOR A BURIAL GROUND
WOULD THAT BE.
A DIFFERENT COST SO WE'D LIKE TO
LOOK MORE INTO THAT TO SEE IF
THAT WOULD REDUCE COSTS AND THEN
THE SECOND THING -- THAT WE'D
LIKE TO LOOK AT IS -- THERE WERE
INITIAL TALKS ABOUT HAVING TO
REMOVE QUITE A LARGE AMOUNT OF
CEMENT FROM THOUGH -- THE ACTUAL
A RUNAWAY AND SOME SUGGESTIONS
HAVE BEEN COULD YOU ACTUALLY
BRING THE DIRT TO PUT IN ON TOP
OF IT VERSES REMOVING IT --
WHICH YOU WOULD PROBABLY NOT DO
IF YOU WERE HAVING IT BE RETAIL
OR HOUSING BUT IN THIS CASE FOR
A DIFFERENT PURPOSE SO THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS TO BE
HAD ON AND ALSO.
TO POSSIBLY LOOK AT ENTERTAINING
AS WAS NOTED THERE IS NOW A
THIRD SITE IN A DEVELOPER HAS --
PRIVATELY AGREED TO PUT UP SOME
FUN SO WE WILL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION IF WE GET IT OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS --
AS I SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH MR
UMBERG I'M QUITE FAMILIAR WITH
THIS BILL -- IT IS  SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MS
AGAR CURRY WAS THE FIRST ONE IN
LINE SO WE'LL GO TO HER HER.
AND THEN WE'LL.
GO TO MISTER NAZARIAN AND THEN
MR DAILY.
GOOD MORNING HONORABLE TEARING
MEMBERS AB DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH THE SUPPORT --
TERMINATION OF THE CHAIR SO A
BEEF EIGHT FIFTEEN PLEASE
PROCEED THAT'LL MAKE THIS QUICK
TWO ALLOWS CAL RECYCLE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS IMPLEMENTED A
DUAL STREAM.
RECYCLING PROGRAM WHEN
DETERMINING IF THEY MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO MEET STATE
RECYCLING GOALS.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE LOCAL TO DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY AND IT DOES
NOT TAKE AWAY LOCAL CONTROL.
ACCORDING TO FISCAL ANALYSIS
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE COST
SAVINGS FOR THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUN BY
REDUCING CONTAMINATION AND THUS
LOWERING RECYCLING COSTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE.
OR NEW TRAINEE QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL --
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE BEST PRIVATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD.
THE RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO WE
KOWSKI.
HI MY COUNTY I WE'LL KEEP THAT
ON CALL.
AS WE GO FOR MISTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER NAZARIAN WAS
NEXT IN LINE COME PRESENT A. B..
FOUR FIVE EIGHT AND YOU'VE
WAIVED ON YOUR OTHER TWO SO TELL
US ABOUT A. B. FOUR FIVE EIGHT
TEN PLEASE OBVIOUSLY. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE NOT HERE -- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FISCAL ISSUES
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GERALD KEEP IT
BRIEF A. B..
FOUR FIFTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW
LICENSE OPTOMETRIST TO BRING
VISION SERVICES AND TESTING TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONFINED TO
THEIR HOMES -- THIS BILL HAS A
MINIMUM OF FISCAL IMPACT -- BY
BRINGING PREVENTIVE I CARE TO
THOSE WHO ARE HOMEBOUND WITH ME
I'M JOINED BY -- SURE MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR CALIFORNIA
STATE OPTOMETRY CALIFORNIA STATE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY.
TESTER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
PLEASE. TO SOME OF THAT WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS -- WE
HAVE DONE EXTENSIVE LOOKING AT
WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE ABLE TO
ABSORB THIS POSITION FEEL THAT
THAT IS A POSSIBILITY AND
DEFINITELY SEE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR EXPANDED SERVICES -- AS A
GOOD USE OF THESE RESOURCES. TO
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A FILE.
YES THE STATE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
ESTIMATES SIXTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS SPECIAL FUND -- ANNUALLY
ON GOING. TO ADMINISTER THE HOME
RESIDENCE PERMIT CERTIFICATIONS
IN ADDITION TO MY ON OBSERVABLE
COSTS TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS
ANY QUESTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECT RESTAURANT VOTE THANK
ALL RIGHT WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD TO RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WIECKOWSKI.
MAKOVSKY AYE.
WE WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTERS MR DAILY
PLEASE COME UP AND TELL US ABOUT
AB FORTY SEVEN DRIVER RECORDS.
GET TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
DISTRACTED DRIVING CAN BE AS
DEADLY AS IMPAIR DRIVING THERE
FOR I'VE INTRODUCED THIS BILL.
TO IMPROVE ROAD SAFETY.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS TO DRIVERS WHO
TEXT WHILE DRIVING OR EIGHT
TIMES AS LIKELY TO BE IN AN
ACCIDENT AS DRIVERS WHO ARE NOT
TEXTING.
THIS BILL STRENGTHENS THE
PENALTY FOR DISTRACTED DRIVING
BY ADDING A POINT VIOLATION ON A
PERSON'S DRIVING RECORD. FOR THE
SECOND OR ANY SUBSEQUENT
CONVICTION WITH ME TODAY IS MIKE
CAN KNUTSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTOMOBILE CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY CAN YOU
SEE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE OUT OF
THE CLUB TRIPLE A THE VERY
MINIMAL EXPENDITURE HERE WILL
HELP US.
AVOID A LARGE NUMBER OF OF DEATH
AND MAKE HIM RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER MEMBER TRUST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT.
BRANCH OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
[inaudible] TWENTY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SIR FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
ANTICIPATES ONE TIME COST OF UP
TO ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
FOR FORMS REVISION AND
PUBLICATION UPDATES.
ANY QUESTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
WE HAVE A QUESTION FOR MS GARAGE
SO.
WITH RESPECT.
TO THERE WAS A STUDY.
FROM IS THAT THE LATEST STUDY
AND NOT.
I BELIEVE SO ARE THE FOR THAT TO
MISTER CANOED SIN WHO HAS THE
BACKGROUND RESEARCH.
YEAH THERE WAS -- A STEADY JUST
WANNA KNOW IF THE STUDY INCLUDED
WHAT.
OF ANY FINANCIAL YOU KNOW
FINANCIAL INFORMATION -- FOR
FUNDING INFORMATION.
IN TERMS OF FINDING A FINANCE
FROM THE STATE YES -- I THINK I
THINK DO YOU VIEWS LOOKED AT A
PRETTY CAREFULLY IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT WHAT IT WOULD COST HIM.
THEY'RE DOING A LOT OF WE
ORGANIZATION NOW SO WE CAN BE
VERY CHEAP TO KIND OF JUST DIAL
THAT INTO THE STUFF THAT'S GOING
ON IN THE THE BILL DOES ALLOW.
FOR A LONG LEAD TIME FOR TO GET
DONE PROPERLY.
AND WHAT'S THE LONG LEAD TIME.
I THINK AT THIS POINT WHERE IT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS WHEN IT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED.
WE DELAYED IT FOR A YEAR BECAUSE
OF OF CONCERNS BY DMV THAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO GEAR UP. FOR
THIS.
THE S. FOR THE S. FOR MORE TIME
AND IN THE OFFER WAS VERY HAPPY
TO GIVE IT.
TO DO YOU HAVE FINANCIALLY ON
THE IMPACT OF INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN WHEN IT'S
LIKE A ONE POINT IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE?
WHAT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S?
OF COST OF INSURANCE AND IT I
JUST WONDER WHAT.
SHOULD KNOW FROM ONLY THE
CUSTOMER MARK FROM OUR
EXPERIENCED ON THE COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS A FAIR
QUESTION FOR MARCH PRINCE POINT
CHANGE BEHAVIOR.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE
OTHER AMENDMENT THAT WE TOOK IS.
ON LIKE EVERY OTHER OFFENSE THAT
IS LIKE THIS OR SIMILAR TO IT
DANGEROUS DRIVING ACTIVITY YOU
DON'T EVEN GET THE POINT ON THE
FIRST INFRACTION.
SO NOT ONLY GET THE LONG LEAD
TIMEWE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ENGAGED
IN A IN A KIND OF A WIDESPREAD.
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN TO HELP
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND YOU SHOULD NOT
BE DOING THIS ACTIVITY IT'S VERY
DANGEROUS THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT IS AS DANGEROUS AS DRIVING
WHILE INTOXICATED -- WHICH WE
HAVE A MUCH BETTER HANDLE ON AND
SO THE FIRST ONE IN THIS CASE IS.
YOU YOU WOULD NOT GET A POINT
FOR THE FIRST INFRACTION IT'S
ONLY FOR THE REPEAT OFFENSE THAT
YOU WOULD GET THE INFRACTION AND
OF COURSE POINTS OR INFRACTIONS
FOR WHICH YOU'D GET A POINT
WHERE OLAF EVERY THREE YEARS AND
SO IT'S KIND OF A REFER THIS.
ONE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WILL
ONLY GET KIND OF THE HARD CORE
OFFENDERS THAT.
JUST DISREGARD THE LAW IN THIS
REGARD.
AND AND THE LENGTH OF TIME OF A
PRIOR CONVICTION.
WITH THE YOU KNOW THREE YEARS
THREE YEAR WINDOW AND ALSO.
THE THREE YEAR WINDOW AND YOU
ALSO.
WHAT IS THE MAGIC BEHIND A THREE
YEAR VERSUS A?
CURRENTLY HOW WE DO IT WE'RE
JUST TAKING THIS PRACTICE THIS
THIS ANOMALY FRANKLY THIS OUT
LIAR AND WE'RE FOLDING IT INTO
HOW WE HANDLE ALL THE OTHER
POINTS INFRACTIONS.
CENTER YET THAT IS DMV.
PRACTICE CENTER POLICY EVERY
YEAR ROLLING -- ASSESSMENT.
AND YOU CAN AVOID THE POINT BY
GOING TO TRAFFIC SCHOOL SO WE
FEEL LIKE.
FOLKS THAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED HAVE LOTS OF OPTIONS TO
AVOID THE NEGATIVE IMPACT AND OF
COURSE THE THE DEATHS AND
INJURIES THE COME FROM THIS
BEHAVIOR -- IS EVENLY
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE
UNIVERSE THE UNIVERSAL
POPULATION AND IT'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND THAT'S THE PIECE
THAT WERE.
REALLY FOCUSED ON A WE FEEL LIKE
WE'VE ADDRESSED SOME OF THE
OTHER POTENTIAL CONCERNS FOR FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION.
JONES HAS QUESTION.
MR DAILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I I
THOUGHT THIS WAS ALREADY LAS I
WAS ACTUALLY SURPRISED AT THE
THIS IS COMING UP AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THS IS
THIS IS NEEDED NOW -- I I THINK
WE'RE PROBABLY. FOUR YEARS LATE
GETTING THIS.
DONE AS A HE ON I'M DRIVE ON THE
FREEWAYS I HAVE A HIGH PROFILE
VEHICLE THAT I DRIVE SOMETIMES.
AND WHEN IN LOOKING DOWN INTO A
CAR THAT'S DRIVING A RADICALLY
ALMOST 1100% A TIME IT'S
SOMEBODY ON THEIR CELL PHONE --
NOT PAYING ATTENTION AS AMAZING
TO ME HOW THEY CAN STARE AT
THEIR PHONE FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME AND PAY ATTENTION
TO THE ROAD.
AND THEN -- OF COURSE AS A
MOTORCYCLE RIDER ON THE FREEWAYS.
IT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS -- ASPECTS OF WRITING
ON THE FREEWAY NAY CURRENTLY AND
IT'S AMAZING TO ME HOW IN THE
LAST -- TEN YEARS THE CONDITIONS
ON THE FREEWAYS HAVE GOTTEN
DRAMATICALLY MORE DANGEROUS.
AS A RESULT OF THIS BAD HABIT SO --
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
THANK YOU FOR STAYING.
WITH IT AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS IN THE
QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I MOVE IS THE MOST MOTION BY
MISTER HILL -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D
DORADO.
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I Y. CASKEY.
OKAY THAT'S THE FINAL WHAT WE
WANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL [inaudible]
SIX ZERO YEAH [inaudible]
YOUR CONSISTENT.
NO OTHER AUTHORS HERE.
SO WE WILL GO.
TO THE LET'S LIFT THE CALL
MISTER BRADFORD HAS JOINED US TO
RELIVE THE CALL ON AB FOR FIFTY
EIGHT NAZARIAN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
THAT'S OUT. SEVEN ZERO EIGHT
FIFTEEN AGUILAR CURRY PLEASE
LIFT CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD
[inaudible]
BRADFORD AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TO TWO SMITH.
FOR MISS SMITH IS HERE YES.
SO COME ON UP.
AND TELL US ABOUT AB.
TEN FIFTY ONE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT SAID TO PASS WITH
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
AND TASTIC I'M GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD RE
ESTABLISH AN EXEMPTION INITIALLY
PUT IN STATUTE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING FACULTY TO EXCEED THE
PART TIME FACULTY COURSE LOAD
CAP.
ALLOWING FOR MORE CONTINUITY IN
CLINICAL NURSING EDUCATION.
UNDER EXISTING LAW COURSE LOADS
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY ARE CAPPED AT 67% OF THE
HOURS PER WEEK A FULL TIME
COURSE LOAD APPROXIMATELY TWO
COURSES.
THIS CAP RESULT AN INSTRUCTOR
CHANGES IN THE MIDDLE OF
ROTATIONS INTERRUPTING THE
STUDENTS LEARNING PROCESS AND
INTERRUPTING THE CARE AT
CLINIAL SITES.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE WOULD PERMIT
PART TIME CLINICAL NURSING
FACULTY TO BE EMPLOYED BY ANYONE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT FOR
UP TO FOUR SEMESTERS OR SIX
QUARTERS ALLOWING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
ACROSS THE STATE TO SERVE AT
LEAST AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE STUDENTS PER
YEAR IN NURSING PROGRAMS AND
ENCOURAGING THE HIRING A
PRACTICED LICENSE NURSES WHO
BRING VALUABLE AND RELEVANT REAL
WORLD EXPERIENCE INTO THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
YEAH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS
SPONSORED AB.
TEN FIFTY ONE IN ADDITION TO THE
POINT ASSEMBLYMEMBER MADE I
WOULD JUST ADD.
THAT THIS BILL REALLY PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR NURSING
PROGRAMS TO REALLY MAXIMIZE THE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS THEY
SERVE. FOR EXAMPLE THE VENTURA
COLLEGE RECENTLY HAD TO REDUCE
THEIR ENROLLMENTS BUT 20%.
AND IT IS IN A IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY WOULD NOT HAVE HAD TO
DO THAT IF THIS EXEMPTION
EXISTED.
WE KNOW THAT OUR PROGRAMS ARE IN
VERY HIGH DEMAND IT ALSO OF
DIFFICULTY GETTING FULL TIME FOR
INSTRUCTORS SO WE THINK THAT AB
TEN FIFTY ONE WILL -- WILL WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO MEETING THE
DEMANDS OF OUR UP PROGRAMS THANK
YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
SIR FILE.
YES USED OF THIS PURPOSE OF
AUTHORITY IS ESTIMATED TO RESULT
IN MINOR COST SAVINGS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
STUDENT THE DECREASE STAFF
TURNOVER COSTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ANTICIPATES
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION I DON'T SEE ANY
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WONDERFUL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D ARE AWESOME.
TORONTO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WAY CASKEY.
MY KASKI AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NOTES TELL ME THAT WE ONLY
HAVE.
ONE MORE OFF THERE WERE WAITING
ON MR GIPSON RIGHT. FOR CALLING
MR GIPSON SO WE WILL GO TO THE
TOP -- AB.
TWENTY EIGHT OBERNOLTE DIPLOMAS
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
THIS BILL CREATES NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND STATE OPERATIONS COSTS IN
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THIS BILL CREATE
SIGNIFICANT PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES. FOR
PARTICIPATING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO ONE HERE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
MAYBE FOURTEEN TWENTY CANNABIS
LICENSING.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
FILE.
THIS BILL REMOVES THE ABILITY OF
LICENSING ENTITIES TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY ADJUST THEIR
FEES AS NECESSARY TO COVER --
THE REGULATORY COSTS. TO THE
EXTENT THESE COST INCREASE FOR
LICENSING ENTITIES THOSE COSTS
WILL NOT BE RECOVERABLE WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY AMENDMENTS.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS N<c.cyan> C --</c>
QUESTIONS AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
AB FORTY THREE MISTER GLORIA ON
MENTAL HEALTH IS OR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS OUR FILE.
YES A FINANCES OPPOSES MEASURE --
AS IT INCREASES COSTS ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET THE
COMMISSION ESTIMATES OF FIVE
POSITIONS IN EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY --
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL ALSO
RESULT IN AN UNKNOWN A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS IN
THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE
STATE ENTITIES FOR PROVIDING
DATA AND CONSULTING SERVICES TO
THE COMMISSION -- LASTLY THE
BILL'S ADDITION OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
REALIGNED MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
MAY RESULT IN PROPOSITION THIRTY
COSTS TO COUNTIES.
AYE TING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTY THREE WE'RE
GONNA SUSPENSE A. B.. ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE TO GLORIA AND MEDI
CAL IS THERE SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS OUR FILE YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES FORTY FIVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
TWENTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
OF WHICH YOU'RE GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING DOWN
THE AB FIFTY MISTER KALRA.
ON ASSISTED LIVING I WAS THEIR
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADELINE COOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
NAPA COUNTY AND CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JACK ANDERSON WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE.
YES -- WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE OTHER PERMIT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES LOCAL
ASSISTANCE COSTS OF FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
WHICH ARE GENERAL FUND BEGINNING
IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THAT WILL
INCREASE TO ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS A
FIFTY SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND ON
GOING BY. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FOR AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF WAIVER PARTICIPANTS --
THIS MEASURE MAY RESULT IN --
SOME SAVINGS A HOWEVER HOWEVER
WE ESTIMATE THESE SAVINGS WOULD
LIKELY NOT MATERIAL MATERIALIZE
IN THE OUT YEARS.
OF FINALLY I WOULD NOTE THAT IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR PROPOSAL
WAS CONSIDERED DURING THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
A PROCESS -- BUT WAS NOT
INCLUDED.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION AB
FIFTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
SB SIX TWENTY FIVE BY MISTER
KALRA ON SERVICE CONTRACTS.
YOUR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION IS
THERE FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES THE COST FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO UPDATE THE
STATE CONTRACTING MANUAL AND A
DRAFT GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS WILL BE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE.
HOWEVER DID YES ALSO ANTICIPATES
AND INCREASING CONTRACT COSTS
FOR AFFECTED SERVICES AS A BID
PREFERENCE MAY ALLOW FOR HIGHER
BIDS.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
AB SIX TWENTY FIVE OVER SUSPENSE
MOVING TO AB SIXTY ONE MISTER
TRAINING ON GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
SIR SUPPORT. TWENTY HUNTINGTON
SHARP FROM THE HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
PERSECUTORS HERE WE HAVE LOS
ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
IN SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION COMMA.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
RE WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AT A COST INCREASES.
THE POOL OF THOSE ELIGIBLE TO
FILE THESE ORDERS WILL VASTLY
INCREASE -- WHICH BRINGS ON IT --
MORE COURT COSTS AS WELL AS
INCREASED STRAIN ON THE APPS
SYSTEM.
WHICH WOULD AS WE ALL KNOW HAS A
SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG.
ALSO THIS IS UNNECESSARY AS ANY
OF THE THE PARTIES THAT ARE
CONTEMPLATED BRING THESE ORDERS
CAN GO THROUGH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CURRENTLY THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GOVERNMENTS
CALIFORNIA WITH THE REASONS
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE WE ARE
NOT POSITION THANK YOU.
THE GERMAN MEMBERS ROY GRIFFITH
ON THE UP THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION WE POSES
MEASURE THANK YOU.
OTHERS SEEING THAT IS HER FILE.
ARE YOU GUYS COMING UP.
NOT.
SURE.
FIVE WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL DOESN'T
POSSESS THE DATA REQUIRED TO
ESTIMATE POTENTIAL WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THIS BILL -- BUT
ESTIMATES THAT THERE FISCAL
IMPACT TO THE COURTS WOULD BE
MINOR AND AFFORDABLE.
BY CREATING THE POTENTIAL FOR
ADDITIONAL MISDEMEANOR CRIMES
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT
ON THE COUNTY JAIL POPULATION --
AS WELL AS IMPOSE NEW COSTS AND
WORKLOAD ON COUNTIES WHICH
CREATES ADDITIONAL FISCAL
PRESSURE ON THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
EMILY THIS BILL COULD CREATE
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
A CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS
WELL AS LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. TO DEVELOP AND TRAIN
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
PROTOCOL AND PROCEDURES FOR
DRESSING AND EMPLOYEES REQUEST
FOR A GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER.
THE NEED FOR TRAINING -- WOULD
BE A SCHOOL DECISION OR EMPLOYER
DECISION BUT WOULD LIKELY BE
WEIGHED AGAINST THE RISK OF
LITIGATION COSTS GIVEN THE
POTENTIAL FOR LEGAL COMPLEXITY.
INHERENT IN THIS NEW AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL COULD ALSO RESULT IN
COST TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES TO
DEVELOP AND TRAIN STATE AGENCIES
ON THE PROCESS AND PROTOCOLS FOR
FILING PETITIONS.
THE COSTS OF THIS AT THIS TIME
UNKNOWN.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTY ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
MYSTERY GIPSON IS HERE TO TELL
US ABOUT AB.
SIXTEEN FOURTEEN ON VEHICLE
LICENSE PLATE PILOT PROGRAM.
MR GIPSON GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTEEN OF FOURTEEN WHICH WILL
EXTEND HE SUNSET DATE OF FOR
THE CURRENT DMV REGISTRATION
TECHNOLOGY PILOT PROGRAM. TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT THE DMV IS ABLE TO CONTINUE
WITH A THIS PILOT -- WHILE A
REPORT IS FORTHCOMING -- THAT
WILL INFORM RATHER IT SHOULD BE
ADOPTED STATEWIDE THE COST OF
THIS IS VERY MINOR BUT WILL
PROVIDE A GREAT VALUE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
PEOPLE OF STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT
REPRESENTED WAS JIM LIGHTS WHO
REBEL WHO WILL -- TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN FOURTEEN GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILL
SHOW AND TELL TODAY -- I'M
REPRESENTING REVIVER ONE OF
THREE TECHNOLOGIES THAT THE DMV
IS EXAMINING IN THIS PILOT
PROGRAM WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DMV IS WORKING ON A FINAL REPORT
WHICH IS DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE --
TO GIVE THEIR THOUGHTS ON THE
PILOT AND SO THAT'S THAT'S NOT
READY YET THE US WE'RE SEEKING
AN ADDITIONAL -- TIME FRAME FOR
THE PROGRAM ONE FISCAL ASPECT I
WILL SHARE IS IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THE D. M. V. AS A
MEASURE TO RELIEVE CONGESTION.
IS WANTING TO REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM THE REGISTRATION
TRANSACTION FOR OWNERS THAT HAVE
ONE OF THESE PLATES.
SO I'M PART OF THE PILOT PROGRAM
WHEN MY VLF KEEM DO I WENT ON
THE COMPANY'S WEBSITE PAID IT
DIRECTLY TO THEM.
AND MY I WAS ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY
PRINT OUT MY TEMPORARY
REGISTRATION CARD IN THE IN THE
DMV HAS ASKED THE COMPANY. TO
REMIT THE REVENUES BACK TO THEM
ON A QUARTERLY SCHEDULE OR OR
SOMETHING WHATEVER THE DMV WILL
WILL ASK THEM TO DO.
SO IT MADE IT VERY EASY AS A AS
A VEHICLE OWNER TO PAY MY
REGISTRATION OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T
HAVE TO VISIT THE DMV AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT -- WHEN THE PROGRAM
IS FULLY AUTHORIZED THAT TO THE
MORE VEHICLE OWNERS CAN DO IT IN
THEDMV SIMPLY RECEIVES THE
REVENUES [inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
OF ANY OPPOSITION.
THERE FILE WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE.
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
PROVIDER.
IN YOUR JUST I THOUGHT I WOULD
HEAR THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL WITH YOU
EVERY TIME.
NO I DON'T I CAN'T AFFORD NOW WE
HAVE A QUESTION MISTER OLIVER
HAS A QUESTION.
YEAH -- I JUST IF YOU COULD TELL
SOMEONE SOMETHING ABOUT THE
RESULTS OF THIS PILOT.
I'M NOT.
TRYING TO GET INTO THE POLICY IT
IS.
SOMETHING THAT MAY JUSTIFY.
THE PILOT HAS EXAMINED A FEW
THINGS IT HAS LOOKED AT HOW THE
COMPANY WOULD INTERACT
ELECTRONICALLY WITH THE DMV TO
BOTH -- UPDATE REGISTRATION SO
ABOUT THREE DAYS AFTER I PAID MY
FEES MY MY TAG JUST
AUTOMATICALLY READ.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SO THAT'S ONE
PIECE OF IT THE OTHER PIECE ON
THE COMPANY AND IS MAKING SURE
THESE THINGS WORK.
IN A HUNDRED AND TEN DEGREE
TEMPERATURE AND IN THE RAIN AND
THE VARIOUS CLIMATES THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT HAS RESULTED IN SOME
CHANGES IN THE IN THE HARDWARE
DESIGN TO ENSURE THAT WHEN WE DO
HAVE A HUNDRED AND TEN DEGREE
DAY THAT -- IT'S WORKING
PROPERLY AND THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
WHAT THE PILOT HAS BEEN FOR AND
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO PERFECT
BOTH OF THOSE ASPECTS THROUGH
THAT PROCESS.
MR HERE AND THAT THAT THE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS OF MY
COLLEAGUE IN AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY WHEN I VISITED REVIVER
NUMBER BUT LAST YEAR.
I WAS SO IMPRESSED WITH IN
LEARNING THE PILOT PROGRAM AND
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL
THAT EXIST AND WILL EXIST IF
THIS IS IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE --
FOR THE CONSUMER IT JUST MAKES
LIFE SO MUCH EASIER SO MUCH MORE
SECURE AND OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE ENDLESS SO -- THAT TO REALLY
THINK IT'S A GREAT TO A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA.
YEAH I MOVE THE BILL MEASURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BEST JOKES [inaudible]
ARE THERE.
THERE'S MS BATES AND SOME OTHER
GUY THE AMERICAN -- MISTER GET
SOMETHING I THINK WE REVIEW THIS --
COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS IN
THIS AMAZING IS IN THE ORIGINAL --
BILL WAS PASSED -- JUST -- QUICK
QUICK -- QUESTION A COMMENT --
IF THIS WERE IN PLACE TODAY HOW
MUCH WHAT IF SOMEBODY WANTED TO
PURCHASE THAT AND HAVE IT ON
THEIR CAR HOW MUCH WOULD IT COST.
THERE'S TWO VERSIONS OF THE
PLATE ONE HAS A GPS THE OTHER
DOES NOT.
THE NON GPS I BELIEVE IS NOW
299-200-99 DOLLARS AND THE GPS
VERSION IS.
THREE NINETY NINE OKAY I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THAT IS THAT THAT'S
NEW THE GPS VERSION THAT'S
INTERESTING.
AND THEN SO I AS ITS CYCLING
THROUGH I'M JUST WONDERING YOU
KNOW.
AS THE PURCHASER OR THE PERSON
ON WITH ON THEIR CAR CAN YOU OPT
FOR THE PLATE APPEARANCE YOU
KNOW I'D I'D LIKE TO GET THE OLD
PALM TREES.
OR THE OLD NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
OLYMPIC PLATES -- IS I CAN BE
PART OF THE PROCESS.
YES TO ANY PLATE THE CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY OFFERS WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN THE DIGITAL PLATE
FORMAT THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS
THAT.
THIS IS -- THE SAME SCREEN AS A
KINDLE BOOK READER IT DOES NOT
COME IN COLOR OKAY SO WE'D OLY
BE ABLE TO DO GRAY SCALE -- NO
PALM TREES AND NO U. S. OLYMPIC
PLATE THANK YOU COULD HAVE PALM
TREES THEY WOULD JUST BE GRAY
GOTCHA ALL RIGHT.
LIKE THE PINK RIBBON IS GREAT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHTS.
THAT'S IT IS BASED YOU HAVE A
QUESTION A QUESTION SHE'S MY
FAVORITE AT OUR STATE.
HIS TO GIVE SO MUCH LIKE THE
CLOTHES THERE'S SHERMAN
EVERYBODY'S RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I BOUGHT RATED I TAKE A
FILE ON THIS.
ONE I DID.
WAS SO LONG AGO I FORGOT.
ALL RIGHT A MISTER HILL MADE A
MOTION WILL CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I TO
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES I WAKE HUSKY.
MAKOWSKI I THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
TO ZERO THANK YOU THAT IS OUR
LAST PRESENTATION INTO WE ARE
LATER WE WILL RECESS -- TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH A. B..
TEN FIFTY FOUR BUT THERE ARE NO
MORE PRESENTATION SCHEDULED SO
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK UP TO AB ONE
THIRTY THREE QUIRK SILVA.
I'M PROPERTY TAX IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT. TWENTY ONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE.
FINANCE ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL
REDUCE REVENUE TO THE GENERAL
FUND BY AT LEAST TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT REVENUE
LOSS WILL GROW IN PROPORTION TO
THE RATE OF INFLATION AND
VARIOUS OTHER FACTORS IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
THIS BILL COULD ALSO CREATE A
PRESSURE TO APPROPRIATE GENERAL
FUND TO PAY PROGRAM CLAIMS THAT
CANNOT BE PAID FROM THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE IN A SPECIAL FUND THAT
SUPPORTS THE PROGRAM.
THE EXTENT OF THIS COST
PRESSURES NOT CURRENTLY KNOWN.
AND FINALLY WE KNOW THAT THE
BILL INCREASES THE COSTS
INCURRED BY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE SCO
ESTIMATES THE COST COULD BE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS AB ONE
THIRTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB ONE SIXTY FIVE GABRIEL GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
[inaudible]
SIR SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE I'LL BE ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI THANK YOU.
SUPPOSITION [inaudible]
SIR FILE.
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFERS
SIR STANDARDS AND TRAINING
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE PENALTY FUND TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT THE TRAINING.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS -- AB ONE
SIXTY FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT ALSO BY
MR GABRIEL ON NONPROFIT SECURITY
GRANT PROGRAM.
SIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE.
THIS BILL CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE BY
CODIFYING THE PROGRAM IN STATUTE --
SPECIFYING IT'S CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION WOULD KNOW THAT
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN INCLUDES A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THIS PURPOSE.
ALL RIGHTS ENOUGH QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB NINE SEVENTEEN REYES CRIME
VICTIMS NON IMMIGRANT STATUS --
IS THERE ARE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE.
YES WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE BUT NO CONCERNS BECAUSE
WILL LIKELY INCREASE COSTS
ASSERTED WITH THE EXISTING STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE DUE TO
ACCELERATING THE TIME FRAME FOR
PROCESSING FORMS -- WE ESTIMATE
THIS COULD RANGE FROM THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO THE
LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. NINE SEVENTEEN
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE MOVING ON
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE FRIEDMAN ON
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
THEIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION IS
OUR FILE.
CALTRANS ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WILL RESULT IN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF INCREASED IT
COST TO REPAIR THE INTERIM
REPORT I DO JANUARY THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH ESTIMATES
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A FISCAL
IMPACT OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
SHEEN NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE GOT
A SUSPENSE A. B. THREE OR FOUR
JONES SAWYER WIRE TAPPING.
YOUR SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SIR FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INDICATES THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL WOULD BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS AB THREE OR
FOUR ORDERS PANTS THAT OBJECTION
AB ONE THOUSAND SEVEN STATE
CIVIL SERVICE ACT AS THEIR
SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS THEIR FILE THE
SCHOOL IMPACT OF THIS BILL IS
UNKNOWN BUT COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
SHORTENING THE TIME FRAME TO
NOTICE AN ADVERSE ACTION AGAINST
AN EMPLOYEE FROM THREE YEARS TO
ONE WILL LIKELY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL DEPARTMENTAL COSTS.
INCLUDING THE HIRING OF
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND OR
INCREASED OVER TIME FOR CURRENT
STAFF TO PROCESS DISCIPLINARY
MATTERS.
PRESIDING HAS A COMMENT THE
MILLER MISTER CHAIR YOU WERE
SLEEPING I I WAS ASLEEP AT THE
SWITCH THERE -- COULD BE BECAUSE
I OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING NO
QUESTIONS AND WITH THE ADDITION
OF MR PRESIDING IS.
RIVETING TESTIMONY WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE A. B. TEN
NINETY TWO ON CHILD SUPPORT TO
THEIR SUPPORT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'RE SITTING
WAY IN THE BACK SO YOU GOT TO
RUN UP EVERY TIME -- PERSONAL
KEEP US HERE ON BEHALF OF CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE. TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND REVENUE LOSSES POTENTIALLY
IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION TEN NINETY TWO ABOUT A
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB THREE OH FORMAR SU CHI TAX
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES.
THEIR SUPPORT CONSIDER
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE.
ACCORDING TO THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD REVENUE LOSSES ARE UNKNOWN
BECAUSE THE BOARD IS UNABLE TO
PREDICT FUTURE MILITARY
DEPLOYMENT AND BUSINESS
OPERATIONS. FOR CONTEXT FOR
EVERYONE HUNDRED SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WOULD BE WOULD
HAVE PAID THE TAX THE RIVER A
REVENUE LOSS WOULD BE EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. THREE OH EIGHT
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
AB THREE FOURTEEN BONTA PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT.
SUPPORT.
UBER ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
RENTS A ROOM WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION.
IS THERE A FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES INDICATES THIS BILL
CREATES UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO STATE
AGENCIES.
A TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL
SHIFTS ACOSTA RELEASE TIME FROM
THE UNIONS TO THE EMPLOYER.
AS WELL AS THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THE LEVEL OF UNION ACTIVITY
WITHIN A PARTICULAR BARGAINING
UNIT.
A FOR THE MORE -- THIS MAY
IMPOSE A NEW REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATED LOCAL PROGRAM.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FOURTEEN WITH
OTHER SUSPENSE A. B. THREE FIFTY
SEVEN THE SYRIAN.
TAX LIABILITY COLLECT DOORS.
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION
THERE FILE.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DID NOT
HAVE A REVENUE ESTIMATE
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME OF THIS
ANALYSIS ABOUT WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND REVENUE LOSSES.
SHE NO OBJECTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FIFTY THERE'S
NO QUESTION TO ME AB THREE FIFTY
SEVEN ABOUT A SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE
YOU SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
[inaudible]
THEIR SUPPORT.
MADELINE COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SHARE FILE.
YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WOULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD WHICH
CREATES NEW GENERAL FUND COSTS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
THAT WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES IT WILL
REQUIRE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL SPECIFIED
APPROACH TO YOU SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT MAY RESULT IN
PROPOSITION THIRTY COSTS TO
COUNTIES OR CREATE COST PRESSURE
TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF STATE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE REALIGNED
SERVICES.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE
WE GOT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A. B..
THREE SIXTY FIVE CRISTINA GARCIA
ON LEAF INTERNSHIP PROGRAM SIR
SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION.
THEIR FILE.
THIS BILL RESULTS AN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS AS
IT IMPACTS MULTIPLE DIVISIONS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES AND REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT.
TING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE SIXTY FIVE A
SUSPENSE.
AB THREE EIGHT EIGHT THE MON ON
HOUSE TIMERS DISEASE HAS THEIR
SUPPORT.
JACK ANDERSON OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
PERSONAL CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF
REPORTERS REVISED OF CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
MADELINE COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
HUNTINGTON SHARP ON BEHALF OF
THE HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE.
FIVE YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE MANY OF ITS
PROVISIONS ARE DUPLICATIVE OF
STATUTORY LANGUAGE IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
THE BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
APPROVED ONE TIME FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE
OPERATION OF A PILOT PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO THE PROGRAM DESCRIBED
IN THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL MAHER
CREATE OUT YOUR GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES IF THERE'S DEMAND
FOR CONTINUATION OF THESE
SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPORTS THE COST OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS FOR
PERSONNEL TO IMPLEMENT THE
ACTION ITEM AGENDAS.
OF THE INITIATIVE AND SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS TO OPERATE THE PILOT.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. THREE EIGHT OVER
THE SUSPENSE.
MR COOLEY SAY BEFORE TWENTY FIVE
ON FIREARMS AMMUNITION SALES.
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES THE NEED FOR
FOR POSITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
SPECIAL FUNDS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ON GOING.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES THE BILL WOULD
RESULT IN -- AMMUNITION SAFETY
IN ENFORCEMENT SPECIAL FUND
REVENUE LOSSES OF APPROXIMATELY
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB.
FOR TWENTY FIVE GO TO
SUSPENSEFUL JUST SKIP OVER A. B..
FIVE TWENTY NINE NOW FORGOT AB
FIVE TWENTY NINE RAMOS SON PSYCH
TO SEEING IF YOU'RE WEEK THIS
TIME.
WAIT -- NINE AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINE PSYC TECHNICIAN OVER TIME.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
YES SIR MIXTURE -- COULD BE
PRESENTED WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS -- THE ANALYSIS IS A
VERY ACCURATE AND AND POINTS OUT
SOME VERY GOOD DETAILS ABOUT A
FUNDING APPROPRIATED IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE NEW PERMANENT
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN POSITIONS
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR PART
TIME POSITIONS WILL ADDRESS THE
MANDATORY OVERTIME ISSUED THAT
DID MOST OF THE SITE TAX ARE
CURRENTLY FEELING RIGHT NOW --
IT'S NOW TIME TO DO AWAY WITH
THE ACT OF OR THE STAFFING TOOL
OF MANDATING.
FORCING SOMEONE TO WORK OVERTIME.
THIS THIS APPROPRIATION IN THE
BUDGET WILL VIRTUALLY ELIMINATE
ALL MANDATORY OVERTIME IN THE
STATE HOSPITALS -- THERE IS A
MINOR -- MANDATORY OVERTIME
GOING ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND DDS MOST OF THE
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS WILL BE
CLOSING BY TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE SO WITH THAT WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF OUR OWN
BILL.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT MR MEMBERS
RANCHER WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION OUR
MEMBERS ARE USED TO BEING --
MANDATED.
TO TO HAVE TO WORK OVERTIME AND
WE'RE GETTING A HANDLE ON IT NOW
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
IT'S LIKE TAX THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THERE FILE.
YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE IS IT MAY RESULT IN
FUTURE COSTS TO THE STATE
ANNUALLY BY ELIMINATING
MANDATORY OVERTIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE TWENTY NINE
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN RAMOS ON
PEOPLE SUICIDE PREVENTION SIR
SUPPORT AS THEIR OPPOSITION IS
THEIR FILE.
THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE IN
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS TO LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL UNKNOWN NON
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
COSTS. TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND TRAINING TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AS LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AS THEY DEVELOP THE
POLICIES ON PREVENTION.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE WE FEEL
THE ESTIMATES OF THE ESTIMATED
COSTS THAT WOULD BE MINOR AND
AFFORDABLE TO THE DEPARTMENT.
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN GOT A SUSPENSE AB FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN CALDERON LONG TERM
CARE.
INSURANCE IS THEIR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS THEIR FILE.
YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IS
DUPLICATIVE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FEASIBILITY
STUDY AN ACTUARIAL ANALYSIS.
OF LONG TERM CARE SERVICES
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACT.
THE DEPARTMENT VENTURE
INCENTIVES ANTICIPATES COSTS OF
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE INSURANCE FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN. TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FOR ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD.
A AND BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING ANTICIPATE A
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE WORKLOAD TO
PARTICIPATE ON THE TASK FORCE.
FINALLY THE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES --
ONE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO CONDUCT THE
FEASIBILITY STUDY AN ACTUARIAL
ANALYSIS.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB
FIVE EIGHTY ONE LEVINE.
SENSING MILITARY MEMBERS --
SERRA SUPPORT.
THE OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE.
A YES WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE BUT NO CONCERNS TO THE
POTENTIAL UNKNOWN FISCAL IMPACTS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION -- WE KNOW
POTENTIAL COST TO THE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDE HEALTH ASSESSMENTS
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL VISITS AND
TRANSPORTATION TOWARD HEARINGS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE
WITH OTHER SUSPENSE A. B..
SIX TWELVE WEBER CAL FRESH SO
SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION IS THEIR
FILE.
YOU DRAW ON THIS MEASURE.
SIGNUP QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX TWELVE AGO
SUSPENSE AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WAS WEBER COMMITTEE
COLLEGE CAREER DEVELOPMENT IS
THERE SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION AS
OUR FILE NEW FILE.
SEEING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WITH A SUSPENSE.
AB SIX TWENTY NINE SMITH
CALIFORNIA VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD SIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
IS OUR FILE.
YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES
THE NATURE OF THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD SYSTEM FOR
COMPENSATING VICTIMS AND IS
LIKELY TO RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. SIX TWENTY NINE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE A. B..
SEVEN SIXTY NINE LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL COUNSELOR SUPPORT.
BACK IN OUR CENTER THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SHARE FILE THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILLS INDETERMINATE BUT
WILL WILL RESULT IN NEW
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM.
THESE COSTS WOULD MOST LIKELY
BEGIN IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND WOULD DEPEND ON
THE BEHAVIOR OF CLINICS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD COSTS AND LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO PROCESS
AN AUDIT RATE ADJUSTMENT
REQUESTS FROM CLINICS.
ALL RIGHTS ENOUGH QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SEVEN SIXTY
NINE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE
ATTENDANCE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
WELL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT FUNDING IS CAPPED
EACH YEAR BASED ON AVAILABLE
PROP NINETY GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES PRIORITIES AND
CAPACITY THIS BILL COULD.
THIS BILL COULD CREATE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING TO THE EXTENT THAT
ADDITIONAL HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
NINE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON
THE ABC SIX THIRTY NINE MISS
CERVANTE.
SEAPORTS IS THERE SUPPORT THEIR
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE.
A KELLY PA NOTES THAT IT DOES
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES OR
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL AND WOULD
LIKELY ASSIGN IMPLEMENTATION TO
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THE BOARD ESTIMATES THIS BILL
REQUIRES ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS COST OF IMPLEMENTATION
ACCOUNT AND SEVEN POSITIONS ON
GOING TO SUPPORT THE TASK FORCE
AND INCORPORATE SPECIFIED WORK
FORCE CONDITIONS IN THE NEXT
COPING PLAN.
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD --
DID NOT HAVE AT FISCAL ANNOUNCES
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME OF THIS
ANALYSIS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB.
SIX THIRTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB SIX SIX ONE MCCARTY --
SACRAMENTO SMOKE AIR POLLUTION
PLANETS OR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AS OUR FILE.
HERE RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES
THIS BILL REQUIRES FIVE HUNDRED
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND --
ANNA AND THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND CONTRACT FUNDS TO CONSULT
WITH THE DISTRICT AND SUBMIT THE
REQUIRED REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL CREATES A
POTENTIAL A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE REQUIRING A HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE OR OR NEW PROGRAM --
FOR WICH FEES MAY NOT OFFSET
TOTAL COSTS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. SIX SIX ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
I AB SIX SIX TWO MISTER
CUNNINGHAM CRIMES AGAINST MINORS
AS THEIR SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION
IS OUR FILE.
WELL THE COST OF THIS BILL ARE
UNCLEAR BECAUSE THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT WOULD BE DETERMINED BY
MULTIPLE FACTORS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO THE CHARGING
DECISIONS OF PROSECUTORS.
JUDICIAL DISCRETION ON THE PRIOR
CRIMINAL HISTORY OF EACH
DEFENDANT WE KNOW THIS MEASURE
COULD IMPOSE NEW COSTS AND
WORKLOAD ON COUNTIES WHICH
CREATES ADDITIONAL FISCAL
PRESSURE ON THE LOCAL CRIMINAL-JUSTICE SYSTEM AND STATE PRISON
SYSTEM.
A BY BROADENING THE SCOPE OF
PENAL CODE SECTION TWO SIXTY SIX
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS CHARGED AND
SENTENCED TO STATE PRISON.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX SIX TWO WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE SB -- SIX SIX THREE
MISTER CUNNINGHAM ON
PROSTITUTION.
IS THERE ARE SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
FIVE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT COULD RESULT
IN A LOSS OF REVENUE FOR SEVERAL
STATE FUNDS ALREADY FACING
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS.
ADDITIONALLY BY MANDATING THAT
75% OF IMPOSED FINES BE EXPENDED
FOR PARTICULAR PROGRAMS THIS
BILL REDUCES THE CURRENT
FLEXIBILITY FOR COUNTIES TO
DETERMINE HOW REVENUES GENERATED
BY FINES ARE SPENT.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB.
SIX SIX THREE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY MISTER MULLIN ON HYBRID
IN ZERO EMISSIONS TRUCKS.
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES
THE GENERAL FUND REVENUE LOSS
FROM THIS BILL WOULD EQUAL NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
FROM.
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND BECAUSE THIS ESTIMATE
IS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
VOUCHERS ACTUALLY AWARDED AND
NOT THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
VEHICLES.
THE RESOURCES BOARD A STATES
ASSESSMENT RESULTS REPRESENTS A
LOWER BOUND AND THAT THE ACTUAL
REVENUE LOSSES COULD BE HIGHER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATE
BETWEEN FIFTY THOUSAND AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS EACH
YEAR BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS AB SEVENTY FOUR BY
MISTER MOM AGO TO SUSPENSE.
AB EIGHT FIFTY TWO BY MS BURKE
ACADEMIC CONTENT STANDARDS.
SERRA FILE ACTION IS THEIR
SUPPORT PROPOSITION FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES THIS BILL RESULTS IN
ONGOING NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND FUND COSTS
POTENTIALLY IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW ACADEMIC CONTENT STANDARDS.
ARE THE DEPARTMENT ADDITIONALLY
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL A NEW STAFF TO
SUPPORT THE ON GOING WORK.
OF THE ADVISORY COMMITTEES A WE
BELIEVE THAT THE COST MAY BE
VARIABLE DEPENDING ON THE NUMBER
OF SUBJECT MATTER AREAS FOR
WHICH THE SUPERINTENDENT.
RECOMMENDS ACADEMIC CONTENT
STANDARDS.
UPDATES -- TO THE BOARD.
SING THE QUESTIONS AB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO A SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
AB EIGHT NINETY ONE PUBLIC
PROPERTY IS THERE SUPPORT
PROPOSITION FILE.
THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE ON
THE IMPACT IT CITIES AND
COUNTIES OTHER TWENTY TWO
COUNTIES IN ELEVEN CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS GREATER THAN THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE -- DEPENDING ON THE
NATURE OF THE FACILITIES
PROVIDED THE GENERAL FUND COST
REIMBURSE LOCAL AGENCIES COULD
BE IN THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT NINETY ONE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE -- AB EIGHT
SEVEN NINE MISTER GIPSON ON
FIREARMS THEIR SUPPORT.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
AB EIGHT SEVEN NINE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD DâN READ WITH NATURAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION HERE IN
OPPOSITION -- THIS BILL LOOKS
TWO X. EXPAND UPON THE RECENTLY
ENACTED AMMUNITION BACKGROUND
CHECKS -- WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT
LAST WEEK IT'S POSED A NUMBER OF
ISSUES AND IS SUBJECT TO ONGOING
LITIGATION -- WHICH THIS THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD EQUALLY --
RECEIVE MOST LIKELY -- THERE'S
BEEN SIGNIFICANT COST
CONSTRAINTS ON BUSINESS IN ORDER
TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW AS WELL
AS DEAL WITH THE RECORD KEEPING --
AND IT'S TAKING SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE EMPLOYEE TIME -- WHICH
MIGHT ARTIFICIALLY INCREASE THE
COST TO CONSUMERS -- FURTHER
THEIR SIGNIFICANT COST TO DO J. --
THEY ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO
READ THEIR MANDATED TO UP
PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON WHAT
QUALIFIES AS A PRECURSOR PART.
OF WHICH GOES FROM EVERYTHING
FROM A HUNK OF METAL ALL THE WAY
UP TO NOT QUITE QUALIFYING AS A
FIREARM FURTHER THERE'S GONNA BE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ON TRAINING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT -- IN ORDER
TO IDENTIFY THESE AND DEAL WITH
THE MANUAL IS.
IN ADDITION TO ENFORCEMENT COSTS
IN IDENTIFYING THIS BECAUSE
THESE PARTS.
I DO GOING TO FIREARMS IN ORDER
TO IDENTIFY AND WOULD REQUIRE
DISASSEMBLY -- I MENTIONED --
COURT COSTS AS WELL AS THIS
CREATES A NEW CRIME SO THERE'S
MORE CONSTRAINTS ON THE COURTS
THERE IN ADDITION TO ANOTHER A
NUMBER OF OTHER ISSUES WITH THAT
ONE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAN BRITISH
REPRESENTING DOLLARS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
ACTUALLY DOZENS AND MAYBE EVEN
HUNDREDS OF DIFFERENT PARTS.
OF FOR A PARTICULAR CATEGORY OF
OF OF OF FARMS IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WILL HAVE TO DO --
HEARINGS AND MAKE IT FOR
REGULATIONS AS TO WHAT IS
INCLUDED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND AS FIREARMS NEW FORMS
ARE INTRODUCED.
THERE WILL BE MORE REGULATIONS I
AND AND IT IS VERY UNCLEAR AS TO
WHAT.
CONSTITUTES AS A PRECURSOR PARK
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE THE THE
THE BILL SAYS -- ANYBODY WHO
KNOWS FIREARMS KNOWS THAT THAT
IS A VERY BIG DEFINITION AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO BE AN EXPENSE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN DOING -- REGULATION HEARINGS
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN --
AND IT'S JUST GONNA BE A
REVOLVING WILL FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED.
BERMAN SHERMAN MEMBERS WERE
GRIFFITH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE SAME REASONS
MY COLLEAGUES BUT OUR PRIMARY
FOCUS IS THE ENFORCEABILITY THIS
IS GONNA BE ENFORCEMENT
NIGHTMARE.
WITH EVER CHANGING LIST OF OF
WHAT OUR PARTS AND ONE ART PARTS
SO FOR THOSEREASONS WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK [inaudible]
THERE.
FIVE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AN ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
MEASURE.
ADDITIONALLY -- ALTHOUGH THE
BILL AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE CHARGE FEES TO
RECOVER COSTS A GIVEN THAT THEY
ARE NOT AUTHORIZED TO START
CHARGING THE FEES UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE A GENERAL PHONE.
THE GENERAL FUND LOAN WOULD
LIKELY BE NEEDED FOR INITIAL
START UP AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS BILL.
SIGNAL OBJECTIONS WITHOUT SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON A. B. NINE FOURTEEN
MISTER HOLDEN.
ON MEDI CAL THEIR SUPPORT.
PERSONALLY CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
FIVE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT CREATES A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES NEW COSTS OF
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH ARE
GENERAL FUND.
ELIGIBILITY A READER
TERMINATIONS ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME COSTS FOR SYSTEM
MODIFICATIONS.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION ESTIMATES
MINOR OF SEVERAL COSTA MONITOR
AND SCREEN INCOMING
BENEFICIARIES.
ADDITIONALLY -- THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATES COST OF
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO MODIFY ITS EXISTING
DATABASE TO INTERFACE WITH THE
DH CS.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINE FOURTEEN WE'RE
GOING TO STRETCH MOVING ON A. B..
TEN SEVENTY FIVE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGIST [inaudible] FOR
SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION THERE FILE.
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON A ONE
TIME BASIS FOR THE CSU TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT IN SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST PROGRAMS.
BY REQUIRING THE CSU TO
IMPLEMENT ADMINISTER A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
AWARD THESE FUNDS TO CAMPUSES.
THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
ENOUGH QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. TEN SEVENTY FIVE
A SUSPENSE.
AB TEN NINETY SEVEN PUPILS
CREDIT RECOVERY PROGRAM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL CREATES COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
COMPILE INFORMATION FROM LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES OPERATING
CREDIT RECOVERY PROGRAMS AND TO
PRODUCE THE RECORD REPORT.
COSTS WILL LIKELY BE IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
NON PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND BUT COULD BE HIGHER OR
LOWER DEPENDING ON THE
COMPREHENSIVENESS OF THE REPORT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL COULD
CREATE LOCAL COSTS FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO COLLECT
AND REPORT THE DATA REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT -- WE
DON'T ANTICIPATE THESE COSTS TO
BE SIGNIFICANT AS FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES AGENCIES TO COLLECT AND
REPORT SIMILAR INFORMATION.
TING A QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION TEN NINETY SEVEN WITH --
SUSPENSE.
AB TEN THIRTY THREE MISTER
COOPER ON STATE EMPLOYMENT NEW
EMPLOYEES SIR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE FILE.
GEN NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN THIRTY THREE
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE.
LIVING TO TEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
MISTER SALAS MENTAL HEALTH UP
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
MADELINE COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION -- FILE.
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET -- WE
ESTIMATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WILL
REQUIRE A TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND TO
HAVE AND 206-100-0100 THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY WANT TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
THING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB.
TEN FIFTY EIGHT FULLER SUSPENSE.
MAYBE [inaudible]
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN TAX.
TAXES ON VEHICLE MODIFICATIONS
FOR VETERANS.
ARE THERE SUPPORT.
I COULD ASSEMBLY OUT OF KERN
COUNTY IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
THEIR FILE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THIS
BILL WOULD CAUSE TOTAL STATE AND
LOCAL REVENUE LOSSES OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR. 1-001-800-0200
DOLLARS OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND.
ACIDITY OF ESTIMATES THAT
THERE'D MINISTRY OF COSTS WOULD
BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE.
SINGLE QUESTIONS AB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN GONNA SUSPENSE.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY THREE MISTER
LOWE BEER PREMIUMS GIFS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL ANTICIPATES THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
EXCEPTIONS WOULD VARY
SIGNIFICANTLY BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS ULTIMATELY
RECEIVED -- FOR COME FOR CONTEXT
AND BASED ON AN ASSUMPTION OF
THE 3% OF LICENSED RETAILERS
THIS WOULD RESULT IN FOURTEEN
HUNDRED NEW INVESTIGATIONS.
WHICH COULD REQUIRE A MINIMUM OF
SIX HOURS A FIELD INVESTIGATION
FIVE HOURS OF AUDITING I WHICH
WOULD TOTAL -- NEW RESOURCE
NEEDS OF APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A SPECIAL FUND ANNUALLY.
SIGNUP QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION LEVIN THIRTY THREE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO MISTER LOW
ON SALE OF NONPROFIT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION.
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
A NEED. FOR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AN ON GOING TO
REVIEW TRANSACTIONS INVOLVING
THE STILL NONPROFIT POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO
ABOUT A SUSPENSE AB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY MS CARILLO.
CONVEYANCE PERMIT SUSPENSIONS
SISTER SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION FILE.
MEN OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
ESTIMATES THIS BILL RESULTS AND
COST OF APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS SPECIAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO CONDUCT
SUSPENSION HEARINGS.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN FIFTEEN
BECAUSE OF THE SUSPENSE A. B.
TWELVE FOURTEEN MELENDEZ.
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AS THEIR
SUPPORT.
SHOP POSITION.
SIR FILE.
THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE A IN
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
BY REQUIRING LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO OFFERS CPR TRAINING
TO ALL EMPLOYEES.
ADDITIONALLY TO THE EXTENT THAT
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES COMPLETED
THE COURSE A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES COULD OCCUR ADDITIONAL
INDETERMINABLE YET SIGNIFICANT
COSTS.
AS THOSE EMPLOYEES -- GAIN
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH CREDITS THAT
MOVE THEM UP OR OVER IN STEP OF
COLUMNS Là PLEA BARGAIN TO PAY
SCALE.
THIS BILL'S REQUIREMENT ON THE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
STAFF INTERSCHOLASTIC ATHLETIC
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES.
WITH PERSONNEL -- WOULD NOT BE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MNDATE -- AS
ELEAZAR ONLY -- AUTHORIZED TO
OFFER THOSE PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER BECAUSE MANY OF THESE
AGENCIES OFFER THE PROGRAMS --
THEY WOULD LIKELY -- INCUR.
SIGNIFICANT COSTS.
IN THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
AB TWELVE FOURTEEN WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE MAYBE TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA CAPITAL
INVESTMENT.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WOULD INCREASE THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
GOT A SUSPENSE A. B..
TWELVE SIXTY MAIENSCHEIN
ENDANGERED WILDLIFE THEIR
SUPPORT.
IT'S LIKE YOU DOES YOUR OWN
BEHALF HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SIR FILE.
YES WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS A RESULT IN ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
OTHER DEPARTMENT EFFICIENT
WILDLIFE INDICATES THE BILL WILL
REQUIRE EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND THEREAFTER.
DEPLOYMENT IN SUPPORT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES.
THING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE SIXTY
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN MENTAL
HEALTH CENTERS.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE.
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THESE CHANGES
WILL CREATE AN UNKNOWN AND
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
CONTINUES APPROPRIATION FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND.
AND MAY BE DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING EFFORTS.
THE COMMISSION IS UNABLE TO FIND
AN EXACT FISCAL ESTIMATE.
AS THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
CURRENTLY DOES NOT SPECIFY THE
NUMBER OF CENTERS OR THE LEVEL
OF SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
CENTERS.
HOWEVER FOR COMPARISON PURPOSES --
THE COST OF ESTABLISHING CENTERS --
CAN VERY AND FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WAS ALLOCATED TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. TO
ESTABLISH TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE ON TWO
CAMPUSES IN THE PAST.
SHINGO QUESTIONS AB FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE SANTEE AUGEREAU.
MENTAL HEALTH PILOT PROGRAM
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
SUBJECT TO AN APPROPRIATION IN
THE BUDGET ACT OR ANY OTHER
STATUTE. TO EXTEND THE FUNDING
IS AVAILABLE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
TOTAL STATE OPERATIONS COSTS OF
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ONLY.
THREE TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR SINGLE QUESTIONS -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
AGO THE SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WEEKS ON CAL FOR
ASH.
YOUR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS THERE FILE WOULD
NEUTRALIZE MEASURE.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS WITHOUT A
WITHOUT A SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WEBER SUSPENSE.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN CHAN
REVENUES FROM PROPERTY TAXES
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE ANNUAL
REDIRECTION OF APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE FROM CATER FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS TO THE CITY OF BREA.
THIS WILL GENERATE A
PROPORTIONATE ANNUAL INCREASE IN
THE STATE'S PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND OBLIGATION.
IN A QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPECT'S A. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX HIGHLY ROUTE
NINE ONE NINETY THREE
RELINQUISHMENT SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
REPRESENTING PLASTER COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND THE
CITY OF LINCOLN IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION THERE FILE WOULD
NEUTRALIZE MEASURE.
SINGING -- QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
WILL GO THE SUSPENSE AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE ARAMBULA.
GROCERY EMPLOYEE CERTIFICATION
IS THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE FILE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN COST OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND IN FIRST YEAR
AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT
AND ENFORCE THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS MEASURE.
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY ONE TO RUBIO
TAX CREDIT FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS AS THEIR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
DROP SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOT CREAMED RESEND
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS -- VERY
PROUD TO BE THE SPONSOR OF A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIDE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
PROPOSITION IS OUR FILE.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND REVENUE
LOSSES OF FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WITHOUT ANY
QUESTIONS AB FIFTEEN NINETY
GHOST THE SUSPENSE.
AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE RUBIO
DREAM A RESOURCE LIAISONS.
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE.
THIS BILL WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE BY
REQUIRING EACH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO DESIGNATED
DREAMER RESOURCE LIAISON.
WE ESTIMATE.
TING STATE WHAT PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND COSTS WOULD
BE APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
ASSUMING EACH COLLEGE WOULD HIRE
ONE SUPPORT SERVICES STAFF
MEMBER TO SERVICES LIAISON AT A
COST OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE
ABOUT A SUSPENSE.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO MISTER
BERMAN SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE SIR
SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION IS THERE
FILE.
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE.
WITHOUT QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY ONE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
THAT IS ALL OF THE BILLS ON FILE
BUT FOR ONE SHOULD MISTER
HOLDEN'S BILL.
GET OUT OF POLICY COMMITTEE WE
WILL HEAR THAT LATER TODAY SO WE
ARE GOING TO RECESS.
AT THIS MEETING UNTIL LATER
TODAY THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE.
HEARING FROM THIS MORNING WE
HAVE A QUORUM -- WE ARE HEARING --
THE LAST BILL THAT WAS ON OUR
DOCKET.
WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL.
TEN FIFTY FOUR BY MR HOLDEN
MISSED MR MAYS AND MS BURKE.
AND THERE MAY BE SOME OTHERS
THAT I DON'T KNOW BUT THAT'S THE
TRIUMPHANT.
AND WITH THAT WILL BEGIN WITH
MISTER HOLDEN PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT SB. FOR A. B..
TEN FIFTY FOUR IF YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO
BE BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE TODAY.
A WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
EARLIER TODAY AND SENATE ENERGY
AND REAL TO COVER A GOOD DEAL OF
THE POLICY PIECES AROUND THIS
BILL -- WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S
A EXPRESS INTEREST ON THE FISCAL
IMPACT AND SO WE WILL HAVE --
REPRESENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CHOI SAID -- AS A PART
OF OUR PRESENTATION WITH MR MAYS
AND I WILL SERVE LEAD OFF AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE.
WELL ONE OF OUR CONSULTANTS GIVE --
SURVEY OVERVIEW OF THE SAFETY --
COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL.
AS WE ALL KNOW THIS IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE -- IS ONE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
AND A HALF.
LAST YEAR EXTENSIVE DEBATE
RESULTED IN SB NINE A ONE WHICH
WAS ALSO INTENDED TO STABILIZE
THE FISCAL SITUATION OF OUR
UTILITIES.
I WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN FROM EXTENSIVE HEARINGS
REPORTS.
AND DEBATES AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR STRIKE FORCE REPORT.
AND THE RECENT NINE OH ONE
COMMISSION REPORT.
ALL EFFORTS CONCLUDED THAT WE
MUST TAKE THE NECESSARY STEPS.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE FISCALLY
STABLE ELECTRIC UTILITIES IN THE
STATE WHICH CAN KEEP.
THE LIGHTS ON IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CUSTOMERS AND OUR
ECONOMY.
THAT IS THE CRITICAL THING
ENSURING THAT CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
IS STRONG AND CONTINUES TO BE
PROTECTED.
STILL UTILITIES ARE THE BACKBONE
OF OUR ECONOMY IN THE NECESSARY
BACKGROUND OF OUR DAILY LIVES.
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR WHICH WE ALL
SHARE RESPONSIBILITY.
HAS CREATED A NEW REALITY IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE CONSEQUENCE IS
THE WILDFIRES WHICH ARE MORE
FREQUENT MORE DANGEROUS AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE.
IN MANY INSTANCES UTILITIES HAVE
FAILED TO MAINTAIN THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE RESPONSIBLY.
IN OTHER CASES UTILITIES HAVE
HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DAMAGE
CAUSED BY FILLED INFRASTRUCTURE
UNDER INVERSE CONDEMNATION EVEN
IF THEY DID NOTHING WRONG.
THESE TWO FACTORS THOUGH HAVE
COST THE BOND RATING AGENCIES TO
DOWNGRADE OUR UTILITIES. ONE
WENT TO JUNK BOND STATUS AND
THEN BANKRUPTCY ANOTHER FACES
THE SAME PLATE THIS SUMMER IF WE
DO NOTHING.
THE UTILITIES PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
MAYBE CLOSE BEHIND AS THE MARKET
ACTIONS HAVE CASCADED AFFECT.
THIS LEADS TO INCREASE BORROWING
COSTS FOR THE UTILITIES.
WHEN THEY BORROW AS MAJOR
BUSINESSES DO THOSE INCREASES
COSTS THOSE INCREASED COSTS WILL
INCREASE CUSTOMER COSTS BY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY?
THEIR ONLY ALTERNATIVE WILL BE
NOT TO OPERATE AT ALL AND GO
INTO BANKRUPTCY.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WILL PAVE THE
WAY FOR UNPRECEDENTED SAFETY
INVESTMENTS BY THE I. O. U.'S
WITHOUT PROFITS. FOR
SHAREHOLDERS FOR SAY I USED TO
BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR WALL
FOR SAFETY RECORD AND
PERFORMANCE AND PROTECT
CUSTOMERS AND TAXPAYERS FROM
HOLY BEARING THE COST OF
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
THIS BILL PACKAGE WILL
FACILITATE CUSTOMERS ACCESS TO
SAFE RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
POWER BY PROVIDING A DURABLE
SOLUTION. TO THE PROBLEMS
ARISING FROM UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL'S ESTABLISHED A WIDE A
NEW WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION.
INITIALLY WITHIN THE CPUC.
NO LATER THAN JANUARY TWENTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
DIVISION WILL BE TRANSFERRED TO
THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SAFETY WITHIN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
THE BILLS ALSO ESTABLISHED
PROCEDURES AND STANDARDS
APPLICABLE TO CUT CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE PROCEEDINGS AND
STANDARDS APPLICABLE -- TO THE
IMPACT OF THOSE WILDFIRE THOSE
WILDFIRES -- CREATE.
CREATING A NEW PRUDENT MANAGER
STANDARD.
AND ESTABLISH A WILDFIRE FUND
AND MECHANISMS TO CAPITALIZE THE
WILDFIRE FRONT.
I'LL NOW TURN OVER TO COUPLE
MIKE A JOINT -- AUTHORS WHO WILL --
PERCENT ON VARIOUS ASPECTS OF
THE BILL OFFERS TURNED TO A
MISTER MAYES AND THEN THIS BURKE.
THANK YOU OF THE SUMMER HOLDEN
I'LL JUST BE A QUICK -- THAT
WANTED TO IMPLIFY OF YOUTH SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT -- SUMMER
HOLDEN WAS -- WAS TALKING ABOUT
WE KNOW THAT THESE INCIDENCES
ARE OCCURRING -- IT IS WHETHER
IT'S A NEW NORMAL MORE TO NEW
ABNORMAL A WE KNOW THAT THESE
WILDFIRES ARE HAPPENING -- 10%
OF ALL LAWS WHAT FAR START IN
THE STATE WERE STARTED BY THE
MLH UTILITIES ONLY 10%.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH THOUGH THE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS OF THE LAST.
TWENTY ADVANCED THE TOP TWENTY
EVENTS EIGHT OF THOSE 2240% OF
THOSE EVENTS WERE STARTED -- BY
ELECTRIC UTILITIES.
WHICH ALSO COVER THOSE -- THREE
I'LL USE COVER 70% OF THE STATE.
SO WE HAVE A CHOICE -- WE
LEARNED DURING NINE OH ONE WE
HAVE ONE OF THREE OPTIONS -- WE
THEIR PRE FUNDED THOSE
INCIDENCES WE POST FUND THOSE
INTO A FOR THE RECORD AND THEN
SAW THE LATER LIKE WE TRY TO DO
WITH NINE A ONE OR ALLOW FOR
BANKRUPTCY.
WE REALIZE BANKRUPTCY IS NOT AN
OPTION WE'VE KNOWN THERE'S SOME
PROBLEMS WITH WAITING FOR THE
EVENTS TO OCCUR AND THEY JUST
DOING COST RECOVERY FOR PER RATE
PAYERS.
SO WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US IS A
WAY FOR US TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM -- ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS.
I'M EXCEPTIONALLY PROUD TO BE
PART OF A TEAM THE THREE OF US
HERE THE AUTHORS HI BUT ALSO I'M
SEVERAL SENATORS THAT WE WORKED
QUITE A BIT WITH AND ALSO -- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TO BE PRAISE
WITH THIS AS WELL BECAUSE THIS
IS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT IT IS
NOT A PERFECT BILL THAT ANYBODY
CAN LOOK AT AND SAY YEP THIS IS
THE BILL THAT I WOULD WANT. TO
TO BE ABLE -- TO TO AUTHOR AND
JUST LIKE I WANT OTHER BE A
HUNDRED TWENTY DIFFERENT
VERSIONS OF THIS -- IF THE IF
EVERY MEMBER THE LEGISLATURE WAS
GOING TO AUTHOR IT BUT WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US.
IS A WAY TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM TO ALLOW FOR FINANCIAL
STABILITY A WITH OUR LOGIC
UTILITIES.
I JUST WELL ONE QUICK THING --
IN THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE US BACK
IN JANUARY WHEN I INTRODUCED AB
TWO THIRTY FIVE WHICH WAS A MY
BILL THE CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE FUND BILL.
WHEN SOMEBODY SAID WELL THEY'LL?
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THE
SHAREHOLDERS PAY TODAY
ABSOLUTELY THERE'S GONNA BE SKIN
IN THE GAME WHAT WE INTRODUCED
SKIN IN THE GAME.
WELL I THOUGHT THAT THAT AMOUNT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
MADE NO MORE THAN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS TURNS OUT THERE'S TEN
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS A
SHARE HOLD YOUR HOLDERS.
AND THEN SOME.
I THINK THIS IS A A A A GOOD NOT
BIPARTISAN A BILL IT'S A NON
PARTISAN BILL BOTH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE A
SUPPORTING THIS AND OUT OF
RESPECT FOR COLLABORATION NOW MY
RESPECT.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TYPE OF
THIS BURKE THANK YOU.
SEARCH.
ON THEIR AGO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS I'M TAX WITH
THE SAFETY PORTION OF THE BILL
AT THIS BILL ESTABLISHES NEW
SAFETY ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S FROM
SHOULDERING THE COST OF A FIELD
ENERGY SECTOR WITHOUT BACK
TRACKING ON THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR AND ITS
COMPANION BILLS WILL ESTABLISH A
NEW WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION AND
ADVISORY BOARD INITIALLY WITHIN
THE PC.
ARE THE BOARD WILL BE COMPRISED
OF EXPERTS EMPIRE PREVENTION AND
SAFETY AND WILL BE MORE NIMBLE
TO RESPOND TO THE CHALLENGES AS
THEY ARISE.
COSTS WILL BE INCURRED BY THE
COMMISSION FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO THE
DUTIES OF THE BOARD REQUIRING
THEM. TO ISSUE SAFETY
CERTIFICATES FOR UTILITIES AND
STAFF TIME RELATED TO RATE
SETTING AND WILD FIRE COST
RECOVERY PROCEEDINGS WITH
REGARDS TO THE RESPONSIBILITY
UTILITIES I'LL USE WILL HAVE TO
SPEND FIVE BILLION IN AGGREGATE
ON FIRE SAFETY AND MEDICATION
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
AND SHAREHOLDERS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO EARN A RATE OF RETURN OR
PROFIT FROM THIS INVESTMENT.
ENCOURAGING INCREASED WHAT WILD
FIRE SAFETY SPENDING AND HIGHER
UTILITY SAFETY STANDARDS A
REDUCE THE OCCURRENCE OF
CATASTROPHIC WHILE BY A RESULT
IN SAVINGS TO THE STATE AND
CONSUMERS.
ADDITIONALLY IF THE BILL IT IS
SUCCESSFULLY REDUCES FUTURE FIRE
RELATED FINANCIAL RISK UTILITY
CREDIT RATINGS CAN REMAIN STABLE
AND EVEN IMPROVE ACCORDING TO
THE LA -- EVERY TIME THE BOND
RATING AGENCIES DOWNGRADE THE
UTILITIES THERE IS A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN THE
COST OF BORROWING FOR THE
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS.
IN ADDITION TO SAVINGS RATE
PAYER MONEY THIS BILL TAKES
STEPS TO DECREASE THE CHANCES OF
FUTURE FIRES INCLUDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SAFETY
CERTIFICATION WITH IN THE
ADVISORY BOARD THAT REQUIRES
UTILITIES TO TIE EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION TO SAFETY
PERFORMANCE.
CREATE A SAFETY COMMITTEE WITHIN
THEIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS COMPLY
WITH THEIR WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS AND PASS A SAFETY CULTURE
ASSESSMENT.
FURTHERMORE IT CREATES A NEW
PRUDENT MANAGEMENT CENTER THAT
ALIGNS WITH THAT EFFORT TO
PROVIDE MORE CLARITY FOR
UTILITIES.
THE PROVISIONS OF AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR AND ITS COMPANION BILLS
WILL I UTILITIES OFFER SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE POWER THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ENDEAVORS
TO MINIMIZE AND PREVENT UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IN DOING SO WE CAN PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA BE FROM
BECOMING VICTIMS.
NOT ONLY OF THE DEVASTATION AND
DESTRUCTION OF WILDFIRES -- CAN
CAUSE BUT THE UNPREDICTABILITY
OF THE UTILITY COSTS AS WELL
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
BUILT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE OTHERS IN.
RESPONSE CENTERS TO WANNA.
YES PLEASE GO FIRST FOR
OPPONENTS HERE SO -- ITEM OF THE
SCIENTISTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN T THE AUTHOR'S
REQUEST I WANTED TO TALK THROUGH.
THE INSURANCE I'M SORRY THE TWO
DIFFERENT FUND US STRUCTURES ARE
INCLUDED IN THE MEASURE TO
PROVIDE TIME FOR TRANSITION FOR
THE MANY ELEMENTS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE TALKED ABOUT
RELATIVE TO SAFETY.
AND MITIGATING FIRE RESCUE TAKE
HOLD SO -- TO PROVIDE TIME FOR
TRANSITION BASICALLY THERE BE
ONE OF TWO OPTIONS ONE IS A
LIQUIDITY FUND.
BILL EQUITY FUND IS THE OPTION
THAT WE THINK WILL NOT BE THE
CHOSEN ONE PEARL DESCRIBED
NONETHELESS BECAUSE IT TEARS THE
CHOICE IS IMPORTANT -- SO THE
LIQUEFIED ESSENTIALLY PROVIDE --
A LINE OF CREDIT TO UTILITIES TO
PAY FOR CLAIMS -- UNTIL THIS IS
TERMINATION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WERE UP PRUDENT AND WAS%
RESPONSIBLE -- FOR FOR PAYMENT
OF THE CLAIMS THE THE THE
INTERNAL AT THE SHORT TERM LINE
OF CREDIT WOULD BE REFUNDED FROM
EITHER CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
SHAREHOLDERS OR CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM -- FROM RATEPAYERS
DEPENDING ON WHETHER THE UTILITY
WAS PRINT OR WAS NOT PRUDENT.
THE SECOND OPTION IS THE
INSURANCE FUND THE INSURANCE
FUND IS THE OPTION THAT WE THINK
WILL BE CHOSEN FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS INCLUDING THE FACT THAT
IT'S THE PATH.
TO THE CLEAR STANDARD THAT WAS
BURKE SPOKE -- TO RELATIVE TO
COST RECOVERY AND IT'S ALSO THE
PATH TO BE ABLE TO HAVING --
SOME GREATER PREDICTABILITY THE
INSURANCE FUND GETS GETS
CAPITALIZED WITH -- TO
CONTRIBUTIONS ONE IS THE TEN AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS THAT
MISTER MAY SPOKE TO FROM GUY
UTILITY CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THOSE
WOULD COME FROM SHAREHOLDERS AND
THEY WOULD NOT BE RECOVERABLE
THROUGH RATES.
THERE ALSO BE TEN AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WOULD BE.
MADE AVAILABLE BY THE EXTENSION
OF THE RATES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING PAID FOR THE PARTNER WATER
RESOURCES -- RATES THOSE THAT
TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BE AUGMENTED WITH OTHER MEASURES
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE UP TO
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS OF CLAIMS
BEING RESOURCES.
THE THE THE BIG ADDITIONAL
CONTRIBUTORS THAT THERE WOULD BE
A LIMIT ESTABLISHED ON PAY OUTS
OF CLAIMS -- TO TO INSURANCE
COMPANIES OF ABOUT 40% AND SO
THE AGGREGATE OF THOSE THREE
COMPONENTS PROVIDES ABOUT FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF RAPING
RESOURCES.
THAT -- THE PROVIDES HERE
RUNNING ROOM UNTIL THE
MITIGATION STEPS THE HARDENING
AND ALL THE OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THEY HAVE THE EFFECT OF REDUCING
THE FREQUENCY AND ITENSITY OF
YOU KNOW UTILITY CALLS WILDFIRES.
THERE ARE CAN BE ADDITIONAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE FUN THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE FUND
UTILITIES WOULD HAVE TO RECEIVE
A SAVE THE CERTIFICATION.
AND AND IF THEY ARE PRUDENT
MANAGERS THEN.
THEN THE FUND WOULD PAY THE
CLAIM AND THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
REIMBURSEMENT IF THEY ARE NOT
THEN THEY WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE.
A REIMBURSEMENT TO THE FUNDED
HAVE TO PAY A DEDUCTIBLE THE
DEDUCTIBLE WOULD BE UP TO A CAP
IF THEY GENERALLY OR OR YOU KNOW
FOR ACTING.
IN IN GOOD FAITH IF THEY ARE
ACTING IN BAD FAITH WAS THERE IS
WILL FULL ACTION THEY WOULD HAVE
TO REFUND THE ENTIRETY OF THE
CLAIMS PAID OUT BY THE FUND.
SO THE MINIMUM CONTRIBUTION.
FROM -- SHAREHOLDERS IN THIS
CONSTRUCT IS ABOUT TEN AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS IT CAN BE
ANOTHER THIRTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IF THE CAP -- OTHER THE
DUCK DOUBLE IS -- IS IS YOU KNOW
IS.
REACHED AND IT CAN BE GREATER
THAN THAT IF THERE'S WILLFUL
ACTION ON THEIR PART AND THEY
HAVE TO RE RE FUND.
THE A 100% OF THE CLAIMS SPADE
THAT HOLD THE AMOUNT OF MONEY --
THAT WHOLE CORPUS IS NOT -- IT'S
NOT COULD NOT BE RECOVERABLE
FROM REPAIR SO THAT'S THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE
INSURANCE.
ONE AND IN MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
A FEW PEOPLE WHO WERE GOING TO
PROVIDE -- TESTIMONY OF VERY
BRIEF TESTIMONY OB PATRICK
MCCOLLUM WHO'S OF FROM UP FROM
THE ASHES I BELIEVE.
THIS YEAR OF THAT WE ALSO I
BELIEVE ALSO HAVE SCOTT WHICH
WITH I. B. W..
AND NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS AS WELL HOLD ON BEFORE
YOU GO TO YOUR WITNESS SO YOU
HAVE A QUESTION MISTER WHITE
HOUSE.
I WANTED TO UNDERSTAND THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CALIFORNIA
AND SHE RESOURCE SCHEDULING
BECAUSE THERE ARE STAFF REPORT
SHOWS THAT THOSE PAYMENT THOSE
OBLIGATIONS FOR THOSE SPONSOR
PAYING OFF THE CONTRACTS.
ARE ARE FILLED UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT MEANS
THAT THAT MONEY WOULD ONLY BE
AVAILABLE I GUESS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
THIRTY SO THIS THEM.
DOES THE MATH WORK OUT IF WE'RE
NOT COLLECTING ANYTHING FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS.
ON THE ON THE ON OUR SIDE OF THE
TEN HAVE BILLION WELL THE DATA
WE ARE RECHARGE RIGHT SO YOU CAN
YOU PLEDGE OF REVENUES INTO THE
FUTURE AND THEN CAN HAVE THE
SECURITIZATION ON THE DOLLARS
GOD THE BASICALLY THAT'S QUITE
BECOMES A QUESTION OF THE
SCHEDULING OF THAT.
SERVICE -- WITH THE EXTENSION OF
THE RATE THE REVENUES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR PAYING THAT WOULD
BE THE THE FOR THE FUN FIRST
BECOMES CAPITALIZED WITH A LOAN
FROM.
THE FROM FROM YEAH AND THEN THAT
THAT GETS IN TURN REFUNDED WITH
THE BONDS THE ONCE YOU MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE INTO THE FUTURE JUST
BECOMES A QUESTION OF THE TIMING
OF THE OF THE OF THE DEBT
SERVICE PAYMENTS SO THAT THE W.
OUR BONDS ARE SCHEDULED TO BE
PAID.
OFF -- NEXT YEAR WHEN THEY GO
THIS FUNDING STREAM WILL BECOME
AVAILABLE SO WE CAN SCHEDULE THE
DEBT SERVICE CONSISTENT WITH
WHEN THE FUNDS WOULD FLOW SO THE
DEBT SERVICE WE COULD.
POSSIBLY MEET THE INCOME AND
THAT WE'RE GONNA CAN SECURITIZED
IT COULD BE BEYOND THE TWENTY
THIRTY PERIOD OF THIS THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE SPOT RIGHT
THE LIMITATIONS ON THIS ON THE
STATUE WOULD BE UP TO TWENTY
THIRTY SIX IF I RECALL CORRECTLY.
TWENTY THIRTY SIX WOULD BE THE
OUTSIDE OF THE OUTSIDE PERIOD
FOR WHEN THE RATE WOULD BE
EXTENDED TO TO PROVIDE COVERAGE --
TO TO KEEP TO PREPAY THE TERRA
HALF BILLION DOLLAR BOND IN THE
ONE TIME SURPLUS MONEY
INVESTMENT FUND THE TWO BILLION
THAT WE SORT OF KICK EVERYTHING
OFF.
THAT GETS REPAID FROM THE I. O.
U.'S CONTRIBUTION THE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE MONEY WAR.
AND THE STATE THE EXPECTATION IS
THAT WILL GET REAP REPAID BY THE
BY THE BONDS AND AGAIN THE BOND
PROCEEDS CAN BECOME AVAILABLE
BEFORE THE THE ACTUAL CASH FLOW
IT JUST BECOMES A QUESTION OF
HOW ONE IS STRUCTURING THE DEBT
SERVICE FOR THE UP ON OKAY.
AND ONE FINAL QUESTION THREE
CHAIR IF THAT'S POSSIBLE -- IS
ON THE THE CPUC THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION -- WE HAVE
A DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COST TO
GOOD TO BE FOR THIS.
CALIFORNIA WHILE SAFETY ADVISORY
BOARD THE PROCESS OF GOING
THROUGH THE CERTIFICATION.
I KNOW THAT THE CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET SUB TO IS INTERESTED THEY
HAVE JURISDICTION OVER P. UC
WHAT'S YOUR ESTIMATE NOW ARE
WHEN THIS STAFF REPORT WAS TEN
IT WAS HIS.
MILLIONS.
SO IT'S SB ONE ELEVEN AB ONE
ELEVEN CONTAIN APPROPRIATIONS TO
FUND THE SAFETY FUNCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH -- THIS MEASURE
FOR THE P. YOU SEE AND IT'S A
TOTAL FOR BOTH THE PC AND THE
RATE PAYER ADVOCATE OF FORTY SIX
POINT EIGHT I BELIEVE IT'S LESS
THAN FORTY SEVEN MORE THAN FORTY
SIX I THINK IT'S FORTY SIX POINT.
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN -- AND
DOLLARS IT TO FUND ALL OF THE
SAFETY RELATED FUNCTIONS OF
IMAGE.
AND FINALLY MISTER MISTER SURE
THERE'S THERE'S A REQUIREMENT
FOR THE UTILITIES TO MAKE
CERTAIN HARDENING AND SORT IN
CERTAIN WILDLIFE WILDLIFE
MEDICATION THERE'S NOTHING IN
HERE THERE'S NO.
COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE OTHER
THAN SB NINE A ONE THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL COMMITMENT FOR THE
STATE FOR LONG TERM RESILIENCY
PLANNING OR WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
OR ANYTHING ON THE STATE SIDE OF
THE FIRE EQUATION.
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL COMMITMENT
BEYOND THOSE REFLECTED IN THE
pREFLECTED IN THE BUDGET ACT ARE
CONSIDERABLE -- WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE THERE
IS AN INTEREST IN FUTURE
DISCUSSION -- AND THERE THERE'S
AND WE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU -- THROUGH THE
BALANCE OF THE SESSION AS WELL
AS THROUGH NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET.
WITH THEIR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING WHAT
WE NEED TO BE DOING TO MITIGATE
AND REDUCE THE RISK AND
FREQUENCY OF WILDFIRES I WILL
RELISH THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT YOU ON THE SUBJECT.
ANYONE ELSE HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THEM.
TO SEEING NO OTHER HANDS.
THE STATE COUNTY -- TO CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
PATRICK MCCALLUM REPRESENTING UP
FROM THE ASHES ASHES WITH A
GROUP THAT WAS FORMED.
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
NORTH AY FIRES IT'S THE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FAMILIES THAT HAVE
LOST THEIR HOMES DO I OWE YOU
CAUSE FIRES IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
IT'S ALSO THE FORTY ONE LAW
FIRMS -- THAT A REPRESENTATIVE
OUR LAWYERS SPENT FROM FRIDAY TO
SUNDAY.
DEEPLY LOOKING TO THIS ANALYZE
IN THIS.
AND I THOUGHT WE WANT A
COMPLIMENT -- SWIMMING HOLDEN
SOME WOMEN MAYES AND BURKE
SENATOR DODD AND SENATOR HILLS
BEEN ACTIVELY LAWCENTER
HERTZBERG AND THE GOVERNOR STAFF
WE THINK THEY GOT IT RIGHT.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR IS THE BEST
HOPE FOR CALIFORNIANS NOT TO GO
TO THE DISASTER THAT I AND MY
WIFE.
THE TWENTY THOUSAND FAMILIES
HAVE GONE THROUGH BUT I WANT TO
TALK QUICKLY ON THREE OF THE
ISSUES NOT ON THE STABILITY TO
THE UTILITY.
BURKE ON A SAFETY.
ON OUR RATE PAYERS IN ON VICTIMS
ON SAFETY IF YOU BILL FROM WHAT
YOU DID IN SB NINE A ONE YOU
TAKE WHAT.
JUDGE ELSA DID IN THE CPUC
ADOPTED. ONE AREA AND THAT THE
WE WERE.
MOST CONCERNED ABOUT IS TO MAKE
SURE THE SAFETY RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE GOING ON RIGHT NOW THE TWO
FIVE TEN FROM YOUR YEARS FROM
NOW IT THAT THEY'RE GOING ON
WITH THIS NEW DEPARTMENT THAT'S
BEEN CREATED.
THEY'RE GONNA HIGHER WHILE FIRE
SAFETY STAFF WE CAN BE ASSURED
THIS GOES ON IN THE FUTURE IN
THIS JUSTIN AND SOMETHING NOW
THAT TAKES PLACE WITH THE FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IT'S IN PLACE.
WITH THE MORE TARGETED
ANALYTICAL RECOMMENDATIONS
WITHIN IT.
WE FEEL MORE CONFIDENT THAT
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY FOR OTHER
VICTIMS TO GO THROUGH WHAT WE
WENT THROUGH.
ON RATE PAYERS HIGHLY
COMPLICATED BUT WE AND THAT
BASICALLY THINK SUBSTANTIAL
SAVINGS EVEN IF YOU TAKE THE T.
W. R. CAPITALIZATION. THIRTY
DOLLARS A YEAR YOU TAKE THAT AS
AN INCREASE WHICH SOME PEOPLE
WOULD ARGUE.
SUBSTANTIAL SAVINGS FOR P.
JEANNIE CUSTOMERS.
MAJOR SAVINGS FOR EDISON
CUSTOMERS.
AND MAY BE FLAT TO INCREASE FOR
SD ANY CUSTOMERS OF WHAT THEY
GET IN LIABILITY IN THE
STABILITY IT PROVIDES THEIR BEST
RASPY ANY WE CAN WALK THROUGH
THE COMPLEXITY ON THAT.
BUT AND HOW YOU GET THERE BUT
THEY TAKE AWAY THE DEEP THE THE
CAPITALIZATION OF SECURITIZATION
OUR RATE PAYERS THEY PUT IT ON
UTILITY.
THEY TAKE AWAY THE PROFIT ON THE
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IF WE GOING
TO JUMP AND STATUS JULY TWELFTH.
THE COSTS GO UP AND IF THERE'S
NO FUND MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
WITHIN THE FINE AND FINALLY FOR
VICTIMS ARE THREE AREAS IT HELPS
VICTIMS.
WE ASK FOR LANGUAGE THEY PUT IT
IN CPUC HAS TO CERTIFY.
THIS IS JUDGE MONTALE GOING ON
BANKRUPTCY WITH PD AND THE THAT
THAT VICTIMS HAVE BEEN ACCO
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED.
ITS LEVERAGE THE PROVIDES
LEVERAGE FOR US AND IT P.
JEANNIE WANTS TO GET IN THIS
FUNDING AT THE MOVE THINK FAST
IN BANKRUPTCY YOU HAVE THE TWO
JUNE TWENTIETH DAY.
THE EVALUATION THE TAKES PLACE.
IS WHAT'S GOING TO PAY FUTURE
VICTIMS IN ADDISON AND WHAT'S
GOING TO PAY FOR FUTURE VICTIMS
MPG NAY THE GOOD FOR VICTIMS
GOOD FOR SAFETY AND GOOD FOR
RATEPAYERS THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH
SHOULD BE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
THERE'S TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES AT P. JEANNIE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND RETIREES. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IT CALIFORNIA
EDISON WITH ANOTHER TWENTY
THOUSAND RETIREES THE PROVISION
OF THIS BILL THAT WE CARE MOSTLY
ABOUT IS THAT IN EXISTING LAW.
THERE IS.
A REQUIREMENT THAT WHEN THERE IS
AN ACQUISITION.
OR A MERGER.
OF A UTILITY OR TELECOM.
THE P. YOU SEE HAS TO DO A
REVIEW AND ENSURE THAT RATE
PAYERS ARE PROTECTED.
THE T..
THE THE A MERGER OR ACQUISITION
IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC.
THAT IS FAIR AND REASONABLE. TO
EMPLOYEES.
IN ABOUT FIVE OR SIX OTHER.
PUBLIC INTEREST RELATED FINDINGS
THAT THEY HAVE TO MAKE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THAT
PROVISION DOES NOT APPLY TO
PARTIAL SALES.
SO NOW THAT WE HAVE HEDGE FUNDS
WHO ARE OWNING AND OPERATING OR
UTILITIES.
THE FEAR IS THAT THEY WILL START
TO CHOP UP AND SELL ASSETS IN
ORDER TO OBTAIN CASH.
IN THOSE ASSET SALES WON'T BE
SUBJECT TO THIS P. YOU SEE
REVIEW PROCESS AND FRANKLY WE
DON'T CARE IF THEY'RE SELLING TO
A PRIVATE OR PUBLIC ENTITY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PROCESS.
IS -- IS ACHIEVED IN THAT IS IN
THE SEA ON PAGE FORTY THREE OF
THIS BILL.
THAT IS SO IF THERE'S HUGE
CAUTIOUS TO OTHER REPAIRS THE P.
YOU SEE CAN PULL MONEY OUT OF
ANY SALE AND MAKE SURE THAT GOES
TO HELP AND TO UNDERWRITE THOSE
RATE PAYERS.
IF THERE'S NEEDS TO BE WORKER
PROTECTIONS IN TERMS OF THE
PENSION AND OTHER BENEFITS THE
P. YOU SEE CAN GO AHEAD AND
IMPLEMENT THOSE AS PART OF THE
APPROVAL CURRENTLY T. MOBILE AND
SPRINT ARE GOING TO THIS VERY
PROCESS.
WOULD ES DE JEANNIE AND EDISON
PROPOSED MERGER YEARS AGO IT WAS
THIS PROCESS THAT THE P. YOU SEE
FOLLOWED AND THEN DENIED THE
MERGER BECAUSE THEY RULED WASN'T
IN THE BEST INTEREST.
RATE PAYERS THAT TYPE OF BLUE
SKY REVIEW IS CRITICAL WE URGE
IN EITHER THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP
AND DO A ME -- TOO I'M WITH THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS AND
MISTER -- OKAY YEP -- CHANCE BUT
HE JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS AND I WANT TO
PRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION -- ON TO CALIFORNIA
ELECTRICAL -- CURRENT LEXICAL
NEEDS MY MEMBER COMPANIES
PROVIDE A PROVIDE CLEAN ENERGY
IS WELLS RELIABILITY PRODUCTS TO
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON THE MARKET IS
A MESS RIGHT NOW -- IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST RATE
PAYER OUT THERE WE HAVE ONE
UTILITY IN BANKRUPTCY WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY CONTRACTS -- THE
INDUSTRY HOUSE WITH THE WITH
THAT UTILITY WE CANNOT AFFORD
ANY FURTHER DEGRADATION OF THE
OTHER TWO UTILITIES AND PUBLIC
UTILITIES OF I SHOULD POINT OUT
ONE OF THEM IS NOW AND NEGATIVE
WATCH -- BASED ON FIRE LIABILITY
TO THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS IN THE FUTURE WHICH
IS A REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF CAPITAL -- IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
CAPITAL FOR RUSSIA HARD THE
SYSTEM -- IT IS -- I I CAN'T --
IT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT -- THAT
WE STABILIZE THE FINANCIAL
SECURITY HERE OF THE UTILITY SO
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD AND ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE THIS IS ONE COMPONENT
OF A VERY COMPLEX PUZZLE BUT
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ONE TO BAY
BASICALLY GET THINGS STABLE SO
WE CAN CONTINUE INVESTING
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO EVERYBODY
ELSE PLEASE DO ME TOO OKAY.
CARE MARTIN ST HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND ALSO THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IN SUPPORT.
DELANEY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION
A LARGE SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION
AND THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION ON SUPPORT.
KERRY HAD AFFECT NEXTERA ENERGY
RESOURCES AND NEXTERA ENERGY
RESOURCES TRANSMISSION IN
SUPPORT.
AB MARGOT ON HAVE A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
CASSANDRA GOTTA BE THE CALVIN
CORPORATION IN SUPPORT.
ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WHICH
DOES LARGE SCALE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND SUPPORT.
CASSIE GILSON ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICIAL CREDITORS COMMITTEE
APPOINTED BY THE US GOVERNMENT
IN THE BANKRUPTCY IN SUPPORT.
MR GENERALIZATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
COME UP AT THE TAIL END OF
SUPPORT TO SAY THAT THE PROCESS
THAT WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH
WITH EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE.
CLEAN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS
BEEN FANTASTIC WE SUPPORT THAT
PROCESS I KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT
SITUATION YOU FIND YOURSELVES IN
WERE NEUTRAL THE MOMENT I WANT
TO SAY IN GIVE A NICE.
COMPLIMENT TO THE FOLKS INVOLVED
AT THE TABLE.
AND MICHELLE DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND TO THE MANUFACTURERS
WELL I JUST WANT TO THANK THEM
AND APPRECIATE THE WORKING WITH
US I KNOW THAT THIS IS BEEN
DIFFICULT -- FOR EVERYONE TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THIS BILL CAN
KIND OF A COP WHICH A LOT FOR
EVERYONE -- BUT I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S BEEN A RECOGNITION OF
THE OF THE CONSTITUENCY THAT IS
BEING REPRESENTED HERE AND WE
ARE GOING FORWARD TO TRY TO FIND
WAYS.
OF RECOGNIZING THAT IN TRYING TO
OFFSET SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF
THEIR OBVIOUSLY THEIR CUSTOMERS
ARE GONNA FEEL.
I APPRECIATE YOU -- COMMITTING
TO DO THAT GOING FORWARD TO
THANK YOU.
ARE THOSE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YOU WANNA [inaudible]
WOODEN.
YEAH JUST TO FROM THERE THAT'S
FINE -- MY NAME IS MICHAEL GERRY.
I AM THE ATTORNEY THAT
REPRESENTS UTILITY CUSTOMERS
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT IN CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE
CASE I ALSO TRIED THE CASE.
IN WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO SHOW AS
THE GENIE WAS NOT PRUDENT.
IN CONNECTION WITH RECOVERING
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN FIRES.
I'M GONNA SPEAK STRICTLY ABOUT
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND NOTHING ELSE BUT
YOU ARE GOING TO BE SIGNING OFF
ON ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS.
OF ADDITIONAL RATES. FOR UTILITY
CUSTOMERS BETWEEN NOW AND THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS [inaudible]
UNLESS [inaudible]
SOMEHOW.
WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME NUMBER
[inaudible]
OF FIRES.
RIGHT NOW THE PROJECTIONS ARE
THE FIRES WILL BE EQUAL TO OR
GREATER THAN WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
HAD.
SO WHAT YOU'RE BEING ASKED TO
INVEST IN.
IS THE CREATION OF COMMITTEES.
THERE ALREADY IS IN THE CPUC A
SAFETY DIVISION.
AND THEY'RE VERY VERY GOOD
PEOPLE.
BUT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN PERMITTED
TO DO THEIR JOBS THEY HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE STAFF.
YOU HAVEN'T GIVEN THE BUDGET.
BAKER DID NOT DO WHAT HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO AND PEAVEY
CERTAINLY DIDN'T DO WHAT HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO [inaudible]
SO.
THEN THE QUESTION IS THIS YOU'RE
BETTING EVERYTHING ON THIS PIE
IN THE SKY.
WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF FIRES IN THE FUTURE.
YOUR VETTING THE ENTIRE WELFARE
THE ENTIRE FINANCIAL WELL FOR OF
THE STATEOF CALIFORNIA.
ON THAT PROVISION.
THAT'S VERY SIMILAR. TO WHAT YOU
WERE TOLD BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND WHEN YOU SAID THAT
THE RATES WHEN THEY SAID THE
RATE WE'RE GOING TO GO DOWN IF
YOU JUST LET ALL THE GENERATION
GO OFF TO THE OUT OF STATE
GENERATORS THAT WOULD LOWER THE
RATES.
AND THAT WAS FALSE THEN.
EDIT BANKRUPTED YOU ALMOST THE
CITY THE KIDS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT RUINED POLITICAL
CAREERS.
ANDYOU'RE BEING ASKED TO DO THE
SAME THING ALL OVER AGAIN.
LAST THING.
THE UTILITIES ARE NOT TAKING
EVEN AS OF TODAY.
ANYTHING YOU'RE DOING TO REDUCE.
THE POSSIBILITY OF FIRES I FOUND
ON JULY THIRD.
I HAVE THE LETTER RIGHT HERE ON
JULY THIRD.
P. JEANNIE WROTE.
AND TELL THE HEAD OF THE SAFETY
DIVISION IS IF YOU SEE.
THEY HADN'T GOTTEN THE
MAINTENANCE DONE ON THE HIGH
FIRE AREAS -- IN FOUR HUNDRED
DIFFERENT INSTANCES AND THEY
JUST WERE GOING TO DO IT BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T HAVE TIME TO GET TO IT.
AND THEY WERE TOO BUSY IN THE
WEATHER WASN'T GOOD THEY
COULDN'T FIND THE PEOPLE AND THE
LETTERS RIGHT HERE SIGNED.
JULY THE THIRD.
SO I JUST ASK YOU TO DO THIS.
BEFORE YOU BUY THIS PIG IN A
POKE.
OKAY BEFORE YOU AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN WHO I HAVE
GREAT RESPECT FOR BUT TO WHOSE
OFFICE LAST YEAR I WENT TO AN AD
BEG THEM. TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
FIRE SAFETY AND THEY SAID NO
WE'RE GONNA DO REGIONALIZATION
INSTEAD AND THEY WASTE ALL LAST
YEAR AND REGIONALIZATION AND SET
A FIRE SAFETY I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GONNA STICK TO THE FINANCE.
I AM GOING TO STICK TO THE
FINANCES BUT MY POINT WHERE FOR
THAT ALL RIGHT WELL OF THE
FINANCES OF THIS.
IF IF IF YOU BELIEVE.
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
REDUCE A REDUCTION -- OF FIRES.
THEN THIS WOULD MAKE SOME SENSE.
FINANCIALLY.
BUT IN ORDER FOR THAT TO HAVE
CREDIBILITY YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S BEING TOLD TO AND WHETHER
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TELLING YOU
THINGS.
HAVE CREDIBILITY AND WHEN
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN TELLS YOU
THAT HE'S BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
HE WAS WORKING ON
REGIONALIZATION ALL LAST YEAR
AND YOU KNOW WHAT BECAUSE THAT
WAS A BIG ISSUE LAST YEAR SO I
JUST ASK YOU PLEASE.
BEFORE YOU VOTE FOR THIS.
SUBJECT THE REPRESENTATIONS THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE REDUCTIONS
IN FIRES TO SOME SORT OF
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS AND NOT
JUST BY IT.
AS IF THE THE IN A CONSUMER TYPE
FRAUD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SING THEN RESTORING CASALE YOU
HAVE A MOTION FROM A STRIKE
CASKEY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER ROGERS ON THEM THANK YOU
AT THE WE'RE GOING TO AND THEN
WE'LL COME TO YOU OKAY.
GO AHEAD. FIVE PICKING UP ON THE
QUESTION ABOUT FIRE SAFETY IN
THE ABILITY TO REDUCE OUR BUYERS
IN THE FUTURE HAS A LOT TO DO
WITH THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
UTILITIES TO DO HARDENING.
WE HAVE A FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
AMOUNT DOUBTS YEAH YOU KNOW
STATED HERE GOES THE HARDENING
IS THAT REALLY ENOUGH BASED ON
WHAT WE KNOW.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD --
SOME CONTRIBUTION TO THAT THERE
WAS GUARANTEED FROM THESE
UTILITIES I THINK THAT WE ARE
BELIEVE THAT -- WILL GET US A
LONG WAY DOWN THE ROAD AND SO --
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THAT IS
SUFFICIENT AT THIS POINT BUT YOU
KNOW AS WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE GIVING
OUR BEST EFFORT TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO TO STAY AHEAD
OF THESE.
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
IMPACT THAT THEY SEEM TO BE
HAVING ON COMMUNITIES.
THE RANGERS SEEMS TO BE HUGE
FIVE BILLION TO THIRTY BILLION
IS ANOTHER NUMBER AND HIM BALFE
NOT PLUGGED INTO WHAT WE'RE
PROVIDING HERE AND I'D LIKE TO
ASK AND IF MY TIME IF I THINK IF
EMPLOYERS SAY ON IT.
GET IT WOULD YOU RUN OVER THE
NUMBERS ONE MORE TIME FOR ME
BECAUSE WHEN YOU STARTED YOU
SAID TO THE WE HAVE THE
INSURANCE FUND WHICH IS GOING TO
BE THE PREFERABLE -- VEHICLE IN
ITS TEN AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS THAT SHAREHOLDERS.
IS TEN I HAVE BILLION FROM THE
SURCHARGE AND THEN WE GOT TO
FORTY MILLION AND SOMEHOW I MISS
WHAT HAPPENED IN BETWEEN THERE.
THE FORTY BILLION OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWENTY
NINE AND THE FORTY COMES FROM
TWO SETS OF THINGS ONE IS
BASICALLY.
THE VALUE TO CLAIMS PAYING
RESOURCES OF CAPPING THE PAY
OUTS -- TO INSURANCE THAT ARE
RECOVERING COSTS SO THAT'S THE
BIG CONTRIBUTOR THE OTHER ONE IS --
IS RE INSURANCE AND THAT IS A
SMALLER ELEMENT BUT BUT THAT'S
THAT'S HOW WE GET FROM TWENTY
ONE TO FORTY BILLION OF CLAIMS
PAYING CAPACITY.
THEN -- ANOTHER QUESTION BEFORE
I TAKE ALL THE TIME.
IF STATED IN THE LEGISLATION OR
THE ANALYSIS ANYWAY HAT IS RATE
PAYER NEUTRAL EXPLAIN HOW THAT
HAPPENS Là IN THE PRESENT AND
THE FUTURE.
OF THE RAPIER NEUTRAL COMPONENTS
SPEAKS TO THE CONDITIONS THAT P.
GENIE IS GOING TO HAVE TO MEET
BEFORE HAS ACCESS. TO TO THE
FUND SO BEFORE -- P. JEANNIE CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO THE FUND -- P.
JEANNIE HAS TO HAVE A PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION.
BY NEXT BY JUNE THIRTIETH OF
NEXT YEAR THAT IS APPROVED BY
THE COURT AND THAT IS APPROVED
BY THE PC.
THE UC HAS TO CERTIFY THAT IT
MEETS A SERIES OF CONDITIONS
INCLUDING THAT IT BE RATE PAYER
NEUTRAL THAT IT PROVIDED -- FOR
FOR COMPENSATION TO VICTIMS --
IN FULL IN THAT MANNER -- IN THE
MANNER -- APPROVED BY THE COURT
THAT IT -- THAT PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION -- FOR FOR FOR PGA
NEED TO MEET ALL STATE RUN
RELEVANT STATE REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THE OUR PS STANDARDS.
AS WELL AS THAT IS -- THE PC
CONSIDER THE RAPIER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR A AND
PROVIDES ADEQUATE -- ADJUSTMENTS
INCLUDING THE POSSIBILITY OF
VALUE SHARING SO THE THE THE THE
PLAN HAS TO BE APPROVED BY THE
COURT AND THEN THE PC WILL HAVE
TO CERTIFY THESE ELEMENTS IN ONE
OF THE CERTIFICATION CRITERIA.
IS THAT THE RESOLUTION OF THE
BANKRUPTCY BE RAPIER NEUTRAL
MEANING THAT THE PAYMENTS -- FOR
FOR VICTIMS THAT HAS TO BE DONE
IN FULL IN A MANNER DETERMINED
BY THE BANKRUPTCY COURT HAS TO
COME FROM SHAREHOLDERS OR OTHER
ELEMENTS NOT FROM A REPAIR
RECOVERY.
SO IF THEY DIDN'T MEET THOSE
CONDITIONS IT WOULD FALL ON THE
SHAREHOLDERS IF THEY DON'T MEET
THOSE IF THEY DON'T MEET THOSE
CONDITIONS THEY WILL NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FUND SO THEY THEY
THE THIS CREATES BOTH.
THE MAN THE CREATES THE PATH FOR
THE RESOLUTION OF THE BANKRUPTCY
IN A WAY THAT IS FAIR TO
RATEPAYERS AND THAT IS FAIR TO
VICTIMS AND IT BASICALLY
ESTABLISHES THE DEADLINE FOR
THAT.
IT BASICALLY SAYS IF THEY WANT
TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE TOOLS
THAT YOU'D BE PROVIDING IN THIS
MEASURE.
THEY HAVE -- TO MEET THOSE
CRITERIA IF THEY DON'T THEN.
THEN THEY THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MECHANISM TO THE TOOLS THAT
PROVIDE THE STABILITY TO ALLOW
THE EXIT OUT OF BANKRUPTCY SO
IT'S IT'S A BIG INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO GET THE BANKRUPTCY
RESOLVE TO GET THE BANKRUPTCY
RESOLVED IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
TO DO IT IN A WAY.
WE'RE RATE PAYERS AND VICTIMS
ARE PROTECTED.
BUT MISTER IF I CAN JUST HAVE
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS THIS POINT IS CLEAR IS THAT
ALSO IN REGARDS THE DEED OF YOUR
CHARGE THE PORTION TO FIND THIS
FROM RATE PAYERS DOESCOME FROM
THAT SEARCH CHARGES CAN EXTEND
OUT THAT WAS GOING TO EXPIRE.
AND THAT DOES EXTEND OUT INTO
TWENTY THIRTY SIX YEAH I
UNDERSTOOD THAT ONE THANKS
[inaudible]
THE ASPEN.
THIS RAZA.
YES ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I
BROUGHT UP -- SINCE EARLY ON IS
HOW THE SAFETY CERTIFICATION
WOULD WORK -- AND TO ME THAT'S
NOT ONLY.
THAT OPENS THE DOOR RIGHT TO BE
ABLE.
TO GET THE GET ACCESS TO THE TO
THE FUNDS -- IN A BIG WAY IF YOU
HAVE A SAFETY CERTIFICATION THEN
IT'S UP.
TO WHOEVER. TO PROVE RUN THAT
THEY IN FACT DID NOT YOU KNOW --
ACT IN A IN A PRUDENT WAY SO MY
CONCERN IS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WHO.
IS MAKING THAT DECISION.
HAS TO BE AS INDEPENDENT
[inaudible]
AS POSSIBLE.
AND WHAT IS MADE THE THRESHOLD
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT SAFETY
CERTIFICATION IS ALSO A VERY
CRITICAL DECISION.
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY SO THAT THIS DOESN'T BECOME.
YOU KNOW I'M EASY LOOPHOLE --
END OF MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
TRUST OF THE PUBLIC IS THAT
THESE ARE.
THESE ARE YOU KNOW ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER THESE ARE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF OF THE
TRUST OF THE PUBLIC'S MONEY.
SO HOW DO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PIECE OF IT.
IS REALLY A SOLID AND AS STRONG
AS IT NEEDS TO BE.
BUT A COUPLE OF ELEMENTS -- THAT
AT FIRST THERE'S A NEW -- A NEW
DIVISION FOCUSED EXCLUSIVELY ON
ON ON ON THE ELECTRICITY --
SAFETY IT STARTS WITH IN THE PC
BUT IT.
IT'S BECOMES AN INDEPENDENT
ENTITY WITHIN THE RESOURCES
AGENCY THAT IS EXCLUSIVELY
FOCUSED ON THIS.
ON THIS ISSUE -- WITHIN TWO
YEARS SECOND PIECE IS THERE BE A
NEW ADVISORY BOARD OF THAT WOULD
BE -- COMPRISED OF APPOINTEES BY
THE GOVERNOR THE THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE THAT WILL BE.
COMPRISED OF NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL EXPERTS ON ISSUES
OF SAFETY AND ISSUES OF OF YOU
KNOW UTILITY UTILITY.
UTILITY SAFETY AND THE THIS IS A
RAPIDLY EMERGING FIELD SO THAT'S
PART OF WHY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE AN ENTITY
THAT'S GOING TO BE EXCLUSIVELY
FOCUSED ON THIS AS WELL AS
BENEFIT FROM THE EXPERTISE OF
NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL EXPERTS.
THERE WILL BE AN ANNUAL WHILE
FAR MITIGATION PLAN THERE WILL
BE PROGRESS REPORTS THERE WILL
BE A LOOK BACK -- MECHANISM AND
THIS WILL BE AN ANNUAL
CERTIFICATION PROCESS THAT WILL
BE DONE BY THE NEW ENTITY THERE
ALSO WILL BE FIELD A LOT IT'S AN
ACTUAL VERIFICATION ON THE
GROUND OF WHETHER FOLKS ARE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING.
AND IT'S KIND OF A THE THE FIRST
YEAR IS GOING TO BE -- IT'S THE
FIRST YEAR THE PROCESS IS NOT AS
RIGOROUS AS IT IS INFUTURE
YEARS JUST BASED ON A REALITY OF
WHERE WE ARE.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT NOT ONLY ARE THERE ROBUST
PLANS FOR THE THOSE PLANS ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED THAT THERE ARE
PROGRESS REPORTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT AND THAT THERE'S ON THE
GROUND.
EXAMINATION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THINGS ARE BEING DONE AS THEIR
WAS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE.
I WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE STILL HAS
OPPORTUNITY DO OVERSIGHT OF THIS
PROCESS THERE WILL BE REPORTS
THAT WILL COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WILL HIGHLIGHT
AND DELINEATE WHAT KIND OF
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE TO WHAT
IS HAPPENING AND THEN WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO CALL AND THE
FOLKS THAT WE NEED TO AND MAKE
SURE THAT.
WERE SATISFIED WITH THE KIND OF
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU'RE GOOD YOU ONCE YOU HAVE
ALL YOUR ANSWERS.
EARLIER TODAY YOU.
ALMOST ALL WEEK.
ALL RIGHT MISTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHARGE WANT TO
GO BACK A REAL QUICK AND FOLLOW
UP ON THE RAY FAIR QUESTION --
IN UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
SURCHARGE ON UTILITY CUSTOMERS
WOULD BE ASSESSED BASED ON A
KILOWATT -- PROPER USAGE.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE DISPARITY IN RATE
PAYERS AND SPECIFICALLY BETWEEN
STORE CUSTOMERS AND NON SOBRE
CUSTOMERS.
RECOGNIZING THAT STILL THERE'S A
MINORITY OF ELECTRICAL CUSTOMERS
HAVE SOLAR -- BUT THE MAJORITY
IS ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD
IT SO ORG OR DON'T WANT TO
CHOOSE TO HAVE SOLAR SO HOW DOES
THAT.
OUR ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT THERE
THERE COULD BE A DISPARITY ON
THAT.
YES THERE IS -- I MEAN I ONE OF
THEM.
WE WE COULD TALK ABOUT THIS IN
FACT EARLY ON WE WERE WE ARE
QUESTIONING WHETHER THE DICKS
EXTENDING THE W. OUR CHARGE WAS
THE PROPER THE PROPER CHARGE.
THE CHURCH THE TRUTH IS THIS IS
ME TALKING I'M IS THAT IT WAS A
PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE -- BACK
IN JANUARY FEBRUARY MARCH I HAD
SEVERAL PEOPLE COMING INTO MY
OFFICE TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
EVERYONE'S AT ALL THE DEED OF
YOUR CHARGES EASIEST WAY TO DO
IT.
WHEN I HAD THROWN OUT THIS IDEA
OF DOING A PER METER CHARGE AND
MAYBE EVEN ON TRYING TO INCREASE
THAT FOR FOR FOR FOLKS THAT LIVE
IN THE THE MORE FIRE RISK PRONE
AREAS OF SAID HEY GUYS ONCE GO?
BRING HIS IDEAS UP BRING IT BACK
TO US NOT ONE IDEA -- CAME BACK
THE PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE WAS
EXTENDED AS THE W. ARE DEDUCTED
OF YOUR CHARGE AND THE TRUTH IS
FOR THE FOR FOR RATEPAYERS FOR
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL IT'S IT'S
GONNA BE HIGHER THAN IT IS FOR
BROTHERS AND FOLKS IN BEEN
PLACES.
LIKE THE DESERT THAT I REPRESENT
THEY ME PAYING MORE THEY CAN BE
PAYING MORE THAN THE AT AND THEN
THOSE THAT ARE NEAR THE COAST
THAT'S THE THAT'S A FACT -- BUT
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT --
I IT MAKES THE MOST SENSE AND IT
IS THE PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE
WILL BE ARGUING ABOUT THAT -- IT
FOR THE NEXT.
YEAR TWO YEARS TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING AND THAT WAS THE
PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE.
AT THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR CLARITY ON THAT AND THEN
ALL OF A AND ALSO YOUR OPENNESS.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S PROBABLY --
YOU KNOW ONE OF MY BIGGEST HANG
UPS ON THIS WHOLE CONCEPT IS THE
NEEDED WE ARE CHARGING.
I THINK FOR ME IT'S IT'S SMARTER --
HE YOU KNOW I REPRESENT A VERY
CYNICAL AREA OF THE STATE WHEN
IT COMES TO TRUSTING GOVERNMENT
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS A CHARGE IT
IS.
SCHEDULED TO GO AWAY AT A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME AND MY
CONSTITUENTS KNOW THAT.
AND AT TO COME BACK TO THEM IN
STATES BEING EXTENDED FOR
SOMETHING THAT WASN'T EVEN
ORIGINALLY PUT IN PLACE -- FOR
IS KIND OF MAKES IT TOUGH.
AND AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE SOME OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THINK ABOUT LIKE
SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS -- AND
AND THE QUESTION BEFORE US -- IS
IF IT'S NOT THIS THAN THAN WHAT
IS IT.
IF IT'S NOT -- PRE FUNDING WHICH
IS WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO
HERE THEN IT'S POST FUNDING WERE
WAITING TO THOSE INCIDENTS
OCCURS AND THEN THEY'RE GONNA BE
PAYING MORE.
AND IF IT'S NOT THAT THAT IT'S
COMEY BANKRUPTCY AND THEN YOUR
REPAIRS ARE GONNA BE PAYING MORE
BUT THE FACT IS IF WE DON'T ACT
ON THIS TODAY.
YOUR RATE PAYERS MY RATE PAYERS
WILL BE PAYING MORE WHICH IS WHY
I'M SUPPORTING THIS -- AND HAVE
BEEN SO AND URGING YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS AS WELL.
MR MAJOR MADE MY FINAL
CONCLUSION BETTER THAN I COULD
HAVE.
THANK YOU THIS BURKE YOU WANTED
AND I WAS JUST GOING TO BACK TO
THE W. R. FEES WE HAVE MET.
AS AS THE CO AUTHORS ALL OF MET
WITH THE LARGE INDUSTRIAL AND
AGRICULTURAL FOLKS AND OBVIOUSLY
THEY DID OF YOUR PIECES IT IS A
COST THAT THEY DID NOT
ANTICIPATE HOW WHETHER.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THEM WE ARE
LOOKING AT A LOT OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT WILL HELP OFFSET
SOME OF THOSE.
SOME O THOSE CHARGES WHETHER
THAT IS CUSTOMER GENERATE
CUSTOMER REGENERATION AND
REMOVING COUNTIES THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS ON THE TABLE I
THINK THAT ARE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO OFFSET
SOME OF THAT.
OKAY SIGNAL MORE QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION MR HOLDEN WOULD
YOU LIKE.
TO MAKE A BRIEF CLOSE.
A MAKE A VERY BRIEF -- EARLY
THIS MORNING -- AND USUALLY I
DON'T RESPOND -- TO CRITICISMS
BUT I THINK IT'S STILL.
PLACE -- WITH MISTER GERRY --
LAST YEAR.
I WAS A PART OF A AD HOC
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
LOOK AT THE ISSUES OF WELFARE IN
THE IMPACT UTILITIES CAME AND
THEY WERE VERY CONCERNED AT THE
VIA THE YEAR WE'VE BEEN WORKING.
FOR A MISS BURKE AND OTHERS WERE
ALSO VERY ENGAGED IN THAT KIND
OF A PROCESS AND I COACH HERE.
OF THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
NINE OH ONE SO.
YES WE WERE WORKING ON
REGIONALIZATION BUT THIS BECAME
MORE IMPORTANT THAN
REGIONALIZATION IF YOU WILL --
AND LAST YEAR WE HAD A GOVERNOR
WHO.
WAS VERY ENGAGED IN THIS AS WELL --
WERE VERY A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE A
GOVERNOR THIS YEAR WHO'S JUST AS
ENGAGED AND WE'RE TRYING TO PUT
FORTH THAT SOAP WAS WAS.
ELOQUENTLY.
OUTLINED A PROSPECTIVE SOLUTION --
TO INVOLVE THE SHAREHOLDERS IN
THIS PROCESS.
WHERE THEIR SKIN IN THE GAME?
AND THAT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PREDICTABILITY FOR THE RATE
PAYERS AND ALSO HAVE A MECHANISM
IN PLACE THAT VICTIMS ARE TAKING
CARE OF QUICKLY.
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT A DRAG
THROUGH COURTS AND PUT AT THE
BACK OF THE LINE AS THEY ARE
CURRENTLY -- AND SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EUROPE.
AND IF I COULD BE BACK ON YOUR
COMING I THINK LAST -- OUR PRIOR
GOVERNOR WAS FRANKLY MUCH MORE
INTERESTED IN REGIONALIZATION --
AT THAT TIME SO -- I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT -- I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY -- ASSEMBLY
THE SENATE REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT
DOESN'T WANT THIS TO WORK -- I
THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A NEED.
FOR ACTION IN THIS MISTER MAYES --
PUT IT TO THE ALTERNATIVES -- TO
ACTION ARE MUCH MORE SCARY THAN
TAKING THIS ACTION TODAY.
WHICH I THINK IS A PRUDENT STEPS
OBVIOUSLY THE CHAIR -- IS GONNA
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE AND WE
HAVE A MOTION AND WITH THAT WILL.
TAKE THE WORLD.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO I'D BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO BY CASKEY.
HI MIKE HUSKY I THE BILL WAS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE WITH ONE ABSTENTION
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH